In Broadcasting?
Are we broadcasting?
How does this work?
I think we are,
I think we are brothers in broadcasting.
I like that.
I think,
yeah,
we want to talk about the brothers in Standup,
in broadcasting.
Broadcasting is like,
isn't that like a signal though?
Like it doesn't,
not only does that,
like,
like when you're sending something through the air broadcast,
I don't know.
I mean,
don't forget that this didn't exist when that term came up.
So this,
they probably would have encompassed this too,
I guess,
but broadcast for whatever reason,
to me it feels like you're sending like all wired signal,
like the old school league TV signal.
Yeah,
it did.
It did.
It,
did that come in off the radio tower?
Yeah.
Imagine what that must have been like when they,
the first TVs came about and you're sitting in your house and all this time
you've just been listening to the radio like an asshole.
And then finally they have this box that you can sit in front of and you,
you get to see an actual image and it's moving around and you know that the
whole country's watching at the same time.
They probably reacted to that.
The way we will react to holograms when I've actually,
like,
say you're in a live action movie st movies,
you can be immersed in,
in holograms eventually.
That's how they,
the way we look at that as how they probably looked at TV,
cause it's just the whole family that just sit around in this shitty black and
white box and just stare at it.
Hold the elections are coming.
Fucking boring stuff.
But that must have been amazing.
Like magic in your house.
Well,
even just the radio before that was magic where they could all sit around a
broadcast like hg wells,
war of the worlds member.
When that,
uh,
that story from,
I guess it was like,
what year was that?
35 it was in the thirties I guess was killing themselves.
Yeah,
I don't know.
I think Snopes attack that and so there's no evidence and they killed
themselves.
Oh,
I didn't know there was like one of those urban myth things.
I that Shit I had that I'm disappointed that documented.
I asked you what?
Oh.
Oh nurse.
So sad about that.
It sounds like one of those things that it's be pretty hard to prove.
Want to go back to 1930 and find out who killed themselves over an Orson Welles
radio broadcast.
Yeah.
People are going to be reluctant to talk about that slow uncle.
Yeah,
Lou his fucking brains out because he believed the actor man was telling the
truth.
Yeah.
He was probably depressed anyway like cause he's obviously a dopey,
probably lost a lot of money in the market crash.
Was it over by 35 I guess it was.
When was the market crash was 35 I know always,
I think I want to say early twenties was it 29 maybe 35 was what was prohibition
33 well that note,
let's go ahead and go.
Well in the 20s to don't forget cause Bullock empires in the 20s I think.
And that's all through prohibition,
right?
I don't know when it ended.
I feel like,
I want to say it ended in 33,
and then marijuana became criminalized and 35 was illegal before that,
or just not know it was illegal before then,
but they didn't call it marijuana.
It was only do zoning called marijuana.
After William Randolph Hearst started printing these articles about blacks and
Mexicans taking this new drug and raping white women and uh,
they called it marijuana.
Oh Wow.
But that was a name for a,
like a wild Mexican tobacco.
That's what marijuana was.
They used to call it cannabis.
I mean,
that's what it was.
It was hemp cannabis and they would,
uh,
they would smoke cannabis and they would smoke hash and all that stuff was the
same plant,
but it was really what they were after was hemp as a commodity.
They were trying to make hemp a commodity,
very difficult to take over for,
uh,
for paper and for cotton.
They'd,
they'd made some new invention called a decorticator and it was going to be able
to really easily process hemp fibers.
That's where all this came from.
Okay.
Supposedly,
and again,
it's,
it's catchy stuff.
It's hard to call this like guy and Eagle Song.
That's the only time I've ever heard that and I heard it was pot warm smell of
has.
Is that what they call them?
Never heard of that.
That's what I heard a and now eagles documentary I want is that Khaleed tested a
rising up through the way.
Always wondered what that name was.
They were saying,
I think it's a name for pot,
warm smell of colitis.
He said the whole thing,
the whole song is about show business or la or whatever,
but I just made me think that makes sense.
That makes sense,
but,
but my point being,
there's no point.
It was a long ass time ago.
People were,
they had so much,
little,
so much,
much,
much less information coming at them every day that just getting that signal
from the radio must must've been a big fucking deal.
Like whoa.
Yeah,
yeah.
Grabbing around with a ball game.
They'd all just sit around and look at it and actually just looking at a fucking
radio and hanging on the,
or the soap operas,
the radio,
a soap operas.
They would do the weekly ones.
Fuck man.
All those guys that did the fully work with the paper is a flyer,
crinkle,
crinkle.
They had,
they had comedies and dramas and some of those are really fucking cool to listen
to today to you're driving,
like if you've got a Gig you're going to listen to when I'm old timey suspense
radio programs.
Dot.
Yeah.
It's like a time machine.
Have you heard Tom Papa's,
it's called come to pop up in a week.
We do that.
He doesn't live at the village Undergrad.
I think he doesn't here in La.
We don't give us all this script to look white in front of a live audience and
they're awesome.
And uh,
he's always got like a weird theme,
like a Christmas theme or Thanksgiving.
And then you wind up reading it and it's getting real audience laughs and it's
so great to act and not have to be off book.
Just hold your fucking script there.
It's like doing a play with a script in your hand.
Wow.
And so he does it live in front of an audience?
He writes all the scripts he does.
Yeah.
But he's,
he's cool.
Like we'll go through one rehearsal like that night and then you just,
you,
you know,
I always change stuff to make it sound like me and he doesn't care and they're
really fun to do.
He's got Matt Damon to Dome Wow.
Really famous friends cause he hasn't bothered them for photos.
Actually actually see him as an equal.
He's a sweetheart,
that guy.
He's a good dude.
I really only hung out with them for the first time when he did my podcast.
I had like met him before,
like I said Hi.
I think maybe at the most,
but I'd never really talked to him before he came in to do the podcast.
He's a great guy.
He's funny too and he's a weird guy.
Like Tom is one of those guys,
like he's clean,
but he fucking murderers on stay.
Like,
you know,
a lot of times you watch a clean guy up there and you're like,
oh you stink.
Papa's was so good bed.
He's a guy that you watched in the cellar like east,
totally clean.
He can perform in front of any audience and you can't even hate and be like,
he's just a funny guy.
Well some people,
that's just what they think of,
you know,
there's nothing with it.
I
think we all,
especially you and I coming up,
we've got kinda got,
there was,
we were in a time we,
we pretty much started around the same time.
Right?
Like you started in the late nineties.
Yeah,
I started in 88 so by the time I'd come to New York it was like 90 91 and you
were just getting started.
So we were both kind of getting started around the same time.
And there was like,
there was clean camps back then and dirty camps.
Yep.
And we were looked at as like the,
the dummies,
like,
oh,
these guys are dirty.
As he finally got out of there,
just dirty.
And they would look at what you're doing is like,
it would have less merit because even though he's killing,
yeah,
he's killing.
But he's just,
he's talking about getting his Dick Sucked by ag dries weird stuff,
you know?
And people would have this like dismissal of it.
Yeah.
That doesn't really exist anymore.
No,
I don't see it as much.
I don't hear many again because I'm not in the open mic thing anymore,
but I don't,
I remember that clean and dirty and I've always thought that they thought there
was so much more valid and cleanliness.
Yeah.
And there's not,
well,
it's censorship.
That's all it is.
Like you tell me you don't have those thoughts or you just don't want to explore
those thoughts on stage.
That's okay.
You don't have to explore those thoughts on stage.
But to pretend that somehow or another,
there's something wrong with somebody else exploring those thoughts on stage.
Whatever the fuck they are,
that they can't be handled in a clever and hilarious way.
Right.
Everything can be,
well,
they were looking at it like,
like there's a difference between just be cause you can be hacky and clean too.
Like hackey dirty guys suck just as much as hacking lean guys do.
I mean it's just,
you know,
guys doing that.
I don't find any of that to be shocking.
But you always know when a guy's up there trying to be shocking,
but sometimes someone just has an idea of what it's going to be like.
If you hear,
oh,
it's dirty,
comma like God,
it's fucking stupid.
But then you'll see someone who is dirty and like really clever and you'll go,
wow,
I didn't even think of that option.
Right.
Stan hope or lotto when he was alive was perfect example.
There's some really filthy funny guy and have we truly funny guy that all of
these people,
whether it was bill Hicks who could be dirty when he only Carsten least were
prior or Kinison or Cleveland or Lenny Bruce,
they were all filthy and yet all these guys are like,
well,
dirty comedy.
Like you mentioned them.
Instead of just going,
Oh yeah,
I'm going to ask that I'm wrong.
And they go,
well you're not him.
Yes,
that's exactly what they say.
They have to say that cause they can't admit they're wrong.
I said that to a guy and an open Mike night when I was an open mic or this guy
was telling me,
you can't swear.
He was telling me,
you know,
you got to stop swearing because you're never going to do TV and we're going to
do kick TV gigs.
If you swear you're not going to get the the tonight show,
you're not gonna,
you're not going to get Letterman.
You're going to be stuck.
You're going to be pigeonholed.
Like you're just going to be one of those guys as bitter doing the road
swearing.
And I was like,
well what about Kinison?
And he's like,
well you're not Sam Kennison.
I go,
well,
well how did he become Sam?
Kinison right.
What about dice clay?
You're not dice clay.
Well this is stupid cause those are the guys I think are really funny.
Right.
What about prior w what would,
if he had listened to you and went totally clean,
this is ridiculous.
Like what do you like,
what do you like?
Well,
cause I like Kennison and Pryor and Hicks and Carlin,
like those are what I think is funny.
And you're telling me that I can't be like them.
I can't do that style.
Right?
Like that's ridiculous.
That's what I think of his comedy.
Like you and I might have a different idea of what you think of his comedy for
you.
It might be Henny young men,
it might be,
you know,
whatever.
Fill in the blank.
Fibber McGee and Molly too,
you know,
whatever.
Could,
you know everybody's got their own style that they're into but the people would
be like real adamant in the clean versus dirty camp.
I don't think that exists anymore.
And I think the Internet is sort of like dissolve those boundaries.
Last TV has gotten harsher too.
It's like,
you know,
you didn't have,
even in 1990 he had cable but you didn't have channels like FX or all of these
daily HPL was really doing original programming where you were actually just
watching comedy shows.
I said fucking them all the time.
So it was easier for them to do that.
But now you just looked like a day to Douche.
You feel like I don't,
sometimes I'll work material out,
I'll take language out of it cause like,
oh yeah I want to try to do this on TV.
So I gotta make sure my Tinder bit is funny,
clean.
Cause if I ever want to do it on TV,
I don't want the punchline to be cut lips and then go,
oh no,
how do I take that out?
Maybe I can go like,
um,
can I,
can I make a trolley callous noise and make it?
That's what you get fucked up when you have to start editing and couponing it
up.
But I've always hated euphemisms anyway.
Like I hate guys.
There was one,
it was one guy was talking about like a dick or a pussy and he would go her ra
and he would whistle.
Can you whistle?
Yeah,
like and it down.
Like that was what he referred to.
It's like either say it or don't but don't whistle.
That's fucking,
that's not cute.
That's not stomach turning is bizarre.
It's bizarre.
Imagine you're talking to a man.
It was just you and him and he couldn't say pussy and he was like her.
Yeah.
Unless he was talking about a girl that,
I might like it,
but I could see the confusion statistic.
It's just really powerful posted.
You could actually whistle out of it.
She said just insane pussy muscles.
Just can suck,
Erin.
It's probably possible if girls can shoot ping pong balls and stuff like stand
up as a joke or that bit rather about when he was in Thailand and he went to
some crazy lady who shoots bananas out of her pussy,
Julia would put the banana and then chop it up,
spitting it out one piece at a time.
Wow.
How about them apples?
Huh?
How about that clamp down?
It's pretty impressive.
I might not be totally true.
I mean who knows?
You know they have a,
you know Sandra $20 to bet they might've played a scam on them too.
They might have sliced it up in advance.
Either way.
Anybody shooting anything under their vaginas?
Pretty God damn impressive.
Yeah.
I think the way I've done it should fall out of a vagina as basically should
stand up or it should just fall out on the floor.
That's the way it puts you should work.
So if you're doing anything above that,
you're impressive with your pussy.
I was reading this article that this woman wrote,
and I really wish I remember who she was,
but she was arguing that size doesn't matter cause if a chick isn't lazy she can
work on our pussy muscles to the point where she could enjoy any deck.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but she was kind of like,
I'll tell you what she was doing.
She was a loose vagina shaming she was doing,
she was shaming.
All these girls were not having the effort to also while sending a signal out
telling guys she's got a tight pussy or she was also telling that guy she's been
dating who's cock is small and she knows it's small.
She was trying to make him feel better.
So she's built her whole philosophy around,
I'm not an idiot dating a guy with a little dick.
I'm not lazy so I can enjoy him to process easier to suck.
And he's probably really good at eating pussy.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Someone just called me.
Some girl just told me a story yesterday we had dinner about a guy with a tiny,
like a micro cock and she opened her fingers about three inches while I'm like,
was it that long?
She goes,
yeah,
and uh,
I'm like,
how was it?
And she said,
oh,
it was fucking awful.
I couldn't feel it.
And I love the honesty.
I hate when women go like,
oh,
it didn't matter.
Yeah,
of course it matters because it matters.
It matters.
Yeah.
This woman was talking about that too,
that we,
here's where size matters is that women want to feel stuffed,
stretched out.
She's like,
but you can achieve that feeling by tightening your pussy muscles.
But I think you might have a point there,
maybe motives.
Maybe it's a combination of all those things.
Maybe there is no right answer.
Maybe you know her pussy is okay and her boyfriend's Dick is okay.
It's just a combination of all of these things that closer to write the article
and maybe she really is loose vagina shaming.
That's a possibility too.
She might let all these bitches know my policies down.
Squeeze,
squeeze the box.
I don't like a pussy that's too snug.
I like a bit of a sloppy and not lose a bit of a,
you know,
like a bit of a fucking horror show
that makes you happy.
Will you look extra lip it some extra meat philosophy.
Crazy.
I'm trying not to,
you know,
it's funny man.
I,
I talked so much about my sexual shit.
I'm trying now to be a good boy again.
Like I'm only four days in to like,
no,
I'm trying not to do porn.
I'm trying not to dirty,
intrigued tax.
It's very cause I'm like,
I'm,
I'm blocking so much shit by doing that.
It's almost like I feel connected to nobody.
I'm always disconnected.
I don't ever feel like I'm,
I'm with another person for real.
I always feel like I'm just looking at them through a window.
So I kind of want to connect and I know I'm blocking myself.
I know that by living this way,
this,
this constant fucking obsession in this constant thing for money is blocking me
from Billy living with people.
That's fascinating.
So the constant looking for prostitutes and the prostitute relationship blocks
you from having honest relationships with people?
Yeah,
cause I came into,
this is the first time I've ever traveled without a computer.
Like I have two computers now.
I've got a newer Mac laptop and I said this will be my good boy computer.
I have literally have nothing in there that I have.
I'm,
I'm ashamed of you could open my work computer and there's not one dirty fucking
photo on it.
There's nothing that's beautiful.
It's just work.
You're a good boy.
I'm trying.
And the other one well you know fucking horror show.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's like the West shore expressway.
It was.
So when you,
what you do is put like tape around it and if you break the seal then you know
you're,
you know,
you fucked up.
You got to seal it up.
You got to see a lit up like a vault and have it be like a symbol of your
sobriety.
Well I got too much stuff on it that I need.
Like there's too many like real photos on it.
I got to clear it off eventually.
But if you start looking,
you start terpene good.
That's the problem.
And I can't delete all my shit.
So I actually have an external hard drive that is a coded like,
you know,
it's a,
it's a pass code and I have in a bank vault because I'm not ready to throw it
all out yet,
but eventually I will.
Hilarious.
Actually bank the bank have,
yeah,
the bank volume.
You got your papers in there and stuff.
That's my phone has got a few dirty things on it,
but I'm going to get rid of them and uh,
I want to know what's going to happen.
I haven't been like that my whole life.
I like the constant,
it's almost like there's times where I feel like just put it down just it's,
it's like,
uh,
you feel like you're buzzing.
It's like a doodle that get off the plane from La.
And the first thing I'm doing is texting dirty and I'm trying to go to the hotel
and fucking look for all this shit and Lakota eeros and go to this one and set
something up.
So I have no connection with my manager or my friends out here.
There's no real communication cause all I'm thinking about is what I'm going to
do after I got to end this fast so I can go there and it's like,
it's like,
it's like a fucking drug and it's like now I just want to stop.
I'll tell you why.
I did a scene recently.
I had a scene in a show called the nick.
It was a scene with Clive Owen.
It was very brief scene and I think I did okay in it.
Um,
you know,
but it was,
it was only like five lines.
I was ready,
I was prepared,
I knew my lines,
I showed up on time and I felt good about it,
but I didn't feel great and I didn't feel 100% connected during the scene.
And I'm like,
I'm not,
what am I so disconnected from?
I'm not fucking scared to act with this guy.
Like I could set I,
you know,
I can stand in front of people and fucking do what I do.
There's no reason I can't do a few lines with this person.
And feel connected.
It wasn't like that kind of an intimidation.
It was just like,
I realize like even in my most comfortable,
when I'm prepared,
I'm disconnected.
Got It.
Doug Davidoff told me that years ago,
he goes,
you'd be a really good actor.
He goes,
but whatever's blocking you,
he goes,
you got something that you do well you got to do is get rid of its block.
And I've thought about that for years.
You know what I mean?
Every time I see stupid dove,
I want to tell him like,
I still think about that,
but,
and I know that.
But you know what I mean?
It's like I see him all the time,
but it's like that fucking death thing blocking it where you feel like I'm just
not,
there's nothing I'm going to do that makes me feel like I'm a part of this
group.
Well,
you should probably add something to your life.
Yeah.
What you should do is probably add like a new thing to be obsessed with.
You know,
like take up a hobby.
Started doing something that,
uh,
like not something like,
look that doesn't sort of have a real end goal,
but something that you enjoy participating in like some sort of a just to do it.
Like,
you know,
for some people it's working out but working out it seems like kind of like if
you do it for that reason,
just like this is my new addiction,
where now it seems like you're,
unless you like really wholeheartedly dive into it,
it seems like you're going to get bored with just like lifting weights and
wanting it,
the gym,
unless that's your thing,
you know,
I think that's Kinda gotta be done for the,
the benefits of the exercise.
If you're really going to get psycho about that,
but maybe a sport or a hobby or something or I mean something like a game or
even a martial art or something,
something where you're,
you're practicing something that you enjoy.
I want to read more,
you know,
like Bill Burr,
we had built bar in recently and he's flying helicopters now and I'm like,
this is what your friends are doing.
Like as a healthy guy,
bill got married and you bill is never a hunk of shit sexually that I know of
but you know,
here's a guy who,
but you know what I mean.
He was always like a pretty straight and narrow guy and he,
he marries a nice girl and he has a,
and I'm like,
why do you have no thing in your life like that?
Like just a normal thing like hey guy wants to fly out.
I got nothing but time.
Right.
I got fucking,
I'm done with the radio at 10 in the morning and I want to read more.
Like I literally can't read anymore.
I get so fucking,
I'm so wired up and I literally have my phone right here.
It's constant.
So I started reading a little bit more like I'm trying just to shut my brain
down.
Once you go to a flip phone,
that's,
what are you doing?
I saw already there by Kade.
There's too many violently.
There's too many legit things I do with it.
Like I said,
a lot of real texts and I do like Twitter and I do like being able to check my
email and play chess and all these things that are not deviant or piggish.
A flip phone would annoy me more than it would help me.
I think you need a genius APP.
What's that Jesus App.
You need something that overwhelms your phone only.
Let's use the apps that are wholesome and in order to,
to use that Jesus App,
you'd probably have to like to unblock it.
Probably have to put all your fingerprints in or something.
It's upgraded a little bit or he's upgraded his phone,
Samsung alias to bullshit.
That's still an old fucking iPhone.
Want to be piece of shit,
flip phone.
But he texted me asking me if he could get a pocket camera and I said,
yeah,
get an iPhone and he's got this.
He's like,
no,
I've got this new Samsung alias deal.
Almost the Shitty iPhone.
He's going back.
He will go back to hard not to.
In this day and age,
you just got to manage it.
You can't ignore the new technology.
It's like ignoring your car because you drive too much.
You just got it.
You got to just balance it.
So does this new shitty phone have apps?
Show me this new shitty phone.
This is it.
So he got something with a keypad.
Let me say like what Apps,
what are we talking about?
This is a flip phone.
How does it,
oh wow.
Oh,
how weird is it?
Touch screen or all Arrow on the,
oh,
so it goes up and back.
It goes both ways.
How weird.
Yeah.
I remember this piece of shit.
This came out like many.
I might have had one of these fucking things I might have ordered that was still
in the stylists era.
What's wrong with him?
With a stylist on the note,
four of you are trying to add the Samsung note four.
Oh my God.
The galaxy note four.
It's fucking amazing.
As it gets better than the iPhone six no,
no.
The iPhone six is a better phone.
It's just better construction.
The apps work better,
the camera's better.
But the stylists on the note four is pretty slick.
Like you could circle things and it has options.
You could like,
you could copy pictures,
send them to your folder,
you could save them like with,
with the stylists,
like say if you're online,
you're looking at something,
you could just
scroll it with the stylist and the stylist will take that photo.
Oh,
okay.
And then you could also like write notes on pictures and send them to people.
Like,
this is you stupid.
You could draw a Dick and calm coming out of it and put it on someone's picture
and just send it to him.
And in seconds you could write,
like I used to write all my standup notes by hand,
like a,
and they even save to Evernote by hand.
It's kind of slick.
So like when I go into my notes,
I'd have certain notes in here that are,
uh,
they're all done from,
from the,
uh,
galaxy note four.
So they're all done by hand.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
so it's like my handwriting.
It's not just,
but it's my handwriting on a little,
you know,
computer don't you like,
like I have a no thing too.
I talked my notes into it,
I talked my notes.
I like just talking a joke idea and half the time he misspells it,
but it's so much easier and I find like I do so many more ideas that way.
I'm prepared so much more for interviews.
You know what,
I'm just reading a book and spitting notes and then I just emailed them to
myself and print them.
Yeah,
I know what you mean.
And the,
the,
the software now is so good at picking up your words.
It's incredible.
What have I signed?
Something Jim,
my dumb phone right to Jen Norton let,
sometimes you have followers.
It's a con.
It's like how stupid are you?
How many times have I said this?
You don't know that Jim is Jim.
I have Alexis that has a navigation feature that you're supposed to,
you know,
take me to one 18 Hollywood boulevard.
It's fucking never right.
No,
I mean never.
I mean,
it's so bad.
I try to talk very clearly so that it understands me and it never gets it right.
I have to do it three,
four times and usually I wind up pulling over.
It's one of those ones that won't let you enter it in because it thinks you're a
fucking baby.
He can't do it while you're driving.
So you have to pull over,
stop your car,
and then you can enter in an address or you could use the voice feature.
The fois feature sucks at thousand decks.
It's really bad.
Yeah,
that's the word.
And it brings out such a rage,
like how do you not have this figured out?
But the voice feature on your phone,
which is Bluetooth into your car anyway,
is amazing.
The Siri like Siri,
take me to Mann's Chinese theater on Hollywood boulevard,
Mann's Chinese theater.
Would you like directions?
Yes.
Boom.
You're on your way.
I mean,
it's really that good.
I'll tell you what's frustrating about Siri though,
is when you're a talking into it,
you need a wifi connection or whatever,
or a good connection when you do a whole thing,
you know?
And I feel like God,
you know,
I just don't know what I wanted to do with my life and all that.
I fly around a whole fucking chapter and I look in that fucking Cock sucker
circle is still spinning and I realized nothing has been said.
Like it's just waiting to find somewhere to grab the information from.
So this time of you got to just talk,
I finally be like,
you can say comma,
let her ride.
You can go come up period while we just have to keep stopping it and doing it.
Point.
Yeah.
Well it's really good for that note pad feature.
The,
what was it called?
The one that's native to the iPhone.
Um,
I was just just,
no,
it's,
I have another one.
Nodes.
Well,
do you know what,
there's,
there's benefits to both platforms.
I think android and iPhone and I liked both of them.
But what I like about android is that it's open and that like pretty much
anybody can create apps for them.
And there's just so much more variety.
So many,
and there's a lot of Goddamn people use it.
And what you don't like about iPhone is that it's like difficult to get your app
approved for the APP store.
But that's also why so many of these things work so well.
You know like I think in some way it stifles innovation in a small way.
Everyone like you're tethered to the apple maybe,
but they have such a pursuit of excellence cause I can totally see it from their
point of view and ultimately the end product is better.
But I used to phones,
I use this phone for like my home stuff,
my personal stuff.
And then I use a Samsung galaxy s five which is a,
it's waterproof.
I like it a lot.
Man.
I have one of those.
I have never fell in love with it.
I like it a lot.
It's um,
there's a lot of good features to it.
I think the size is about the right size cause this is like five and a half
inches.
The other one's five inch,
I think five inches of the right size.
Yeah,
they have a new,
another newer version of that.
That's probably the same as the iPhone six plus.
Yeah,
the six,
the galaxy s six.
It's just coming out I think like in a week or so.
All I know they gave him,
they gave us a bunch of weight.
They've given us phones,
the galaxy,
and they're not bad phones,
but for me,
I'm just,
this is,
I think there's only one you can just go,
that's my phone.
Like you and me.
I tried both platforms and say,
ah,
fuck it.
While if we had an a,
if he had an android and that was the only option when they first came out,
like when the iPhone came out,
you'd be like,
oh my God,
this is fucking amazing.
We're just so used to how good the i-phones are now that it makes it difficult
for almost everybody else,
but even the old light phones look shitty.
I see somebody got a small iPhone.
I'm like,
where are you from?
1930 given new fucking phone.
Especially the one you see that,
that hunk of Shit.
You're like,
look at this stupid aluminum looking back I no flash and the camera dog shit.
Yeah.
Steve Jobs really bugged me.
That was on purpose.
No flash fucking ass.
But they made a dope phone.
I mean they changed the whole game.
That was only like 2007 it's hard to believe.
I know that pre 2007 we all existed without smartphones.
You think of stuff that you ever watch it,
I'll watch a movie from the 80s and I started thinking they have no right.
I'd be like died in 1989 or that person never made a cell phone call like they
missed so much by dying and in 89 or 1990 or you watch a movie and it just seems
so primitive.
Like how did everybody stay in touch without a fall?
You know wherever you are you think is,
oh my God,
it can never get fucking more advanced than this.
And then five years from now you're like,
what a Douche.
I was.
I was out in the wilderness by myself.
Yeah.
Do you remember calling people on the phone and pink psych from their home?
When they weren't home.
He just kept calling.
Yeah.
Ring,
ring,
ring or machine.
What do you have?
Party lines can at a party line.
Did you ever have one of those?
No.
What's that?
It's in New Jersey when I lived there,
I was a kid and a,
you would get a call and see the philosophy of the upstairs people and I think
it rang different for the nortons if for the people upstairs,
so a lot to you,
if you are quiet you can just like pick it up and listen in and then that you
could listen to someone's conversation from upstairs and sometimes they'd go
where I'm on the phone and you have to go.
Oh,
okay.
Different families shared align.
Wow.
Party.
I think it was called a,
I dunno if it was a party line.
I believe it was called the party line,
but it was nothing to do with like 900 numbers.
And did I just make it like less expensive or it's just the only option?
Probably.
I think,
again,
this is in the late seventies when I was,
you know,
10 11 nine years old.
So that's crazy.
Yeah,
I don't remember that at all.
I don't know if I experienced that.
That might've been on the east coast.
I was on the west coast back then.
I was in the west coast from my age seven to 10 where,
uh,
I was living in San Francisco.
Oh,
okay.
I guess seven to 11 and 11 to 13 yeah.
Seven to 11 in San Francisco.
11 and 13 in Florida.
And then Boston.
Yeah.
So that they didn't have the party lines back then.
I don't know if they had,
or if it was just rapport.
People.
We weren't poor,
but we didn't have a lot of money.
I mean,
my dad,
I think you had to work at that point or he was in and out of work from
trucking,
so maybe that was a quite some money saving thing.
We were pretty poor back then.
We were on welfare.
We drank powdered milk.
The whole lear,
I don't know if I ever had powdered milk.
It sucks.
Right?
It's not good.
No.
Yeah,
it's also very nerve wracking when you're a kid and you know that it's down the
powdered milk,
you know?
And you know that like,
times really are tough.
It's just,
it's a creepy feeling like,
Whoa,
we gonna run out of food.
You know,
like people would freak out if you ate too much.
It's like,
you know,
being poor is very stressful to everybody and in comparison to the rest of the
world,
you're rich,
right?
We talked about this before on this show we have,
not you,
but the 1% everybody uses that term.
The 1% the top 1% of ruining everything to be 1% globally.
The top 1% globally,
all you need to make is $34,000 a year.
Wow.
I don't know that.
Yeah,
that's,
I mean I wouldn't say if you made $34,000 a year,
you're poor,
but it's,
it's not rich.
It's,
it's certainly you're in trouble if you have a family.
If you make in $34,000 a year and you have children to feed,
but it's a fucking,
that's not a lot of money.
I guess it all depends on where you live too.
You would have your single,
in New York where you know you may get 34 grand a year.
It's very hard to find a comfortable living space in New York and have a good
life there.
If you're only making 34 it's almost impossible.
It's almost impossible just for your rent.
Your rent might be 34 grand a year.
Jesus Christ.
34 grand a year is only,
what does that a little bit more than two grand a month.
Yeah,
that,
good luck.
Good fucking luck.
Finding an apartment in New York for two grand a month.
Did you ever see where I lived before I came and we did a cribs that opie and
Anthony like 2001 when I lived at Florentine and there was fucking black mall.
We split it.
$900 rent between me,
him and his girlfriend at the time.
And when you walk in,
there's video of it.
They did.
I kept Jim Norton cribs and um,
the old producer Rick and Steve came to my apartment and I thought it was a
great place.
I had no idea what a fucking cess pool I lived in.
And when you look,
there was a picture on the wall and when you moved it,
black mold was in the,
I don't know if you can bring that up.
It's a video.
You don't want the volume,
but you can see it for that's my old place.
There's fucking,
uh,
you could zip in a little bit as we're walking up these steps here.
This was cliffside Park,
New Jersey.
Where'd you guys live?
This cliffside Park,
New Jersey.
Upstairs about six miles from New York.
You could see the river from the end of the blog side parts all black mold on
the wall and up in the corners.
Oh my God.
That shit's really bad for you.
I wonder if that's contributing to my breathing problems.
Bad sleeper.
I guarantee you it did.
But look at,
look at it leaking from fucking down,
um,
from bad picture behind the picture.
You know that we do move the picture and I hope it's right now.
Yeah,
I think we do a move it.
Um,
it doesn't,
it's not,
it's not good.
Brace yourself.
Yeah,
they put that fucking 2000 graphic.
Oh my God.
That's all black mold.
Yeah.
All Bloody Shit,
Jim.
Yeah.
That's really bad for you,
man.
That's insane.
Why is it behind that picture like that?
I think we had a very leaky living room.
When you look down at my room,
I'm not as Florentines all this.
When you,
when you looked at it,
I had a,
uh,
we had a very leaky living room,
which you might see like we had rain coming in all the time.
We used to put like four or five buckets in the living room and it would rain.
Oh my God.
And it was a,
yeah,
that was,
that was our living room.
That was where I lived.
Um,
did Florentine software the same sort of cardiovascular problems?
I don't know him,
you know,
like he,
he had to be,
Jim had so much black mold in his bedroom,
he had died.
That was,
as the roof does,
he gets almost caving and Jim had fucking Bob Tin foil against the whole bottom
third of his wall just to see the black moldy.
Couldn't see it.
What,
but you know what?
I think too,
part of my breathing problems where I think part of my breathing problems or the
way I fucking sexually edge,
I've thought of that,
all that jerking off.
And like a lot of times I hold my breath,
I don't even know.
I'm doing it like when I'm jerking off and I'm like,
you're breathing fucked up man.
Like I really think that that messed up my bio rhythms or whatever.
Like my sleep.
You fucked up your asleep by edging.
I think I do.
It's so much like right before bed.
If I do something dirty and I jerk off,
I can't sleep.
I'm wired and I think I fucked myself up.
Oh my God.
Well I know that that black mold stuff definitely can have an effect on you,
Tom.
Like has had that in his house and you had to demolish like half of his fucking
house did.
If it didn't make it,
he was sick all the time.
He felt like shit all the time.
He's like,
just felt terrible.
It was like immune system was just fucked and he couldn't figure out what was
up.
And then he did some tests and he found that his house was infested with black
mold.
How long did he live like that?
Cause I was there for about three years maximum.
I don't know.
It's a good question.
And I've been out since 2000 or no,
2002.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know how much of a pain in the ass it was or how long it lasts it or
what.
But I know that it was an issue and then he had to,
I know the specifics,
but
I know that he had to demolish like a large portion of his house.
It's a big deal.
They have to cut the windows out and cut the doors out and cut the walls out and
then spray everything for this fucking mold shit and kill all this mall and they
have to make sure they kill all of it.
It's really bad for you.
Yeah,
it's super bad for you.
That's tough.
Like all over your walls like that.
Uh,
you guys were essentially walking through like air that was tainted by that
fungus.
Can you,
can you like,
I have trouble taking deep breath once in a while like I can now,
but did I feel like I get,
something stops me and I can't sleep.
Like Anthony had a great way.
Who says you?
Anthony?
Comeya such a great way of describing anything.
And he said,
yeah,
you have trouble getting that last click and that's a deep breath.
We're clicks.
And you had that final full breath.
Yeah.
But there's times where I can't get to that full click.
Like I get that a lot when I'm laying down and I have to prop myself up on my
right elbow and then I can take a deep breath.
So I don't know if things are sitting wrong inside or whatever.
Well,
you know,
you can do breathing exercises.
I'm not really an expert in these of,
I fucked with them a little bit and I do a,
a version of them when I do a,
the isolation tank sometimes,
or I'll take a one minute breath in and then a one minute breath out.
And so I dragged my inward breath for one minute.
Oh Wow.
And then I drag my outward breath for one minute.
And it requires a lot of discipline because you start panicking,
you know,
start panicking.
Especially when you breathing it out because you've got to push out the whole
breath,
you know?
So if I'm breathing in like a,
I don't want to,
I don't want to give everybody the boring two minute version of it,
but I literally will go like this.
I like clean my system out and get ready and then I'll,
I don't know how long that was but the first,
and it was probably only about 30 seconds probably about getting panicky,
about half of what I do.
I do a full minute.
Are you really beat out?
Because what happens is I'll take a deep breath and then like 10 seconds into my
body goes your full unfinished.
Fucking can't do it.
Hello.
So like if you look at the seven right now on that clock right there and just
start everything and just give yourself,
give yourself a little break and go
God this is boring podcast.
I'm not breathing out but I am.
Yeah,
I just stopped because you're right.
It's like I literally people listening to me breathe and if they would be,
they'd be hoping I stopped.
Just try it folks.
Just give it a try.
Once you get it down then the way I do it in an isolation tank,
cause I do a 60 count a count in my head while I'm breathing and slow as fucking
hard.
It's hard to hold your breath for a minute.
It seems like it shouldn't be.
It seems like,
well the,
the guys that have the world records,
they hold their breath for like seven minutes or some shit like that.
Like David Blaine does he hold his breath for like a 14 minute tiny period.
Yeah.
He had some world record breath.
I think there's like a caveat to that.
He might have ingested some oxygen before he did or something like that.
17 minutes.
Whoa.
If you ingest the oxygen,
that helps.
I don't know.
Brian Count told me that.
Take it with a grain of salt.
Is that what he did?
Really just breathing of the radios.
It's funny.
I should take it was luckily it wasn't the radio.
It would go,
what the fuck is wrong with you table?
It was that.
Um,
but that's uh,
it's a good discipline for breath and there's all sorts of different yoga
breathing called Pranayama and a bunch of other different names.
They have four different styles of breathing,
but breath exercises or like you can exercise your lungs with like deep
breathing exercises where you actually strengthen your lungs and you can
condition your lungs and you can get used to breathing in a way.
Like they have,
um,
a type of breeding they call shamonic breath work where you can go into
psychedelic states like real drug induced states with no drugs and you can do it
all from this,
what did they call it?
Haul off something.
Breathing.
Holla.
Holotropic breathing is at it.
I've never done it,
but Aubrey,
my friend Aubrey has done it a bunch of times and wants to take you to get that
way.
I don't know.
It's a good question.
I think if you took a class in it and then somebody can show you how to do it.
I know I can't pay for shit.
Holotropic breathing.
It's a practice uses that uses breathing and other elements to putatively never
used that word.
Allow access to non ordinary states of consciousness.
It was developed by Stanislav Grof,
a successor to his lad l s d base psychedelic therapy following the suppression
of Legal Lsd use in the late 1960s oh,
that's interesting.
So he came up with that.
Wow.
What a fucking genius.
That guy out of the fact he did a lot of acid before that helped.
Uh,
Brett,
he was always one step away from just being out of his fucking mind to take two
deep breaths and tie again.
The rest of us had to do with the acid.
Probably told them how to teach people.
Yeah.
You know the assets like,
listen man,
we're going to go away for a little bit.
It's going to be a while.
People are going to still talk about us,
but it's going to be a few years probably till the two thousands when really
people just say,
why exactly is this stuff illegal again?
But until then you can do this.
I wonder if it's,
if it's just like a lot of,
you know,
you gotta you gotta you stand up too fast.
If they're breathing too fast,
you can't like this is how fucking much as you.
I don't sleep for shit.
I bet it that my dumps sleep apnea for years,
but I literally will go to the gym,
newer cap and my trainer has me do like literally sometimes walking up the
steps.
I'm tired.
Really fucking awful.
Now you,
you still have the sleep apnea issue and I put the,
I have so many masks,
so many fans of sent me masking cause I'm a stuffy nose.
I hate my fucking nose so much.
You have no idea.
It's always congested.
You got a deviated septum operation.
That's what happened and help.
It really helped it,
but you know,
you know what I mean?
Now instead of being completely stuffed all the time,
it's partially stuffed.
Most of the time it's much better because I have allergies but I can't get used
to in mass comm.
Claustrophobic,
which you should probably live in Arizona.
You should force opie to live,
move to Arizona to do the show.
It's dry air.
Yeah.
I don't know if that would help them.
A lot of hookers.
Yeah.
I was in there recently in Phoenix.
Um,
did I partake?
I don't think I did.
No.
He's a good boy in Phoenix.
He's a good boy.
Good boy.
No,
no hooking and Phoenix.
I like Phoenix.
It's a fun fucking town.
They're wild ass people.
It's a,
it's an interesting town.
It doesn't get enough respect.
Yeah.
And have a good God downtime there.
Warren Sapp wait,
what a weekend.
He hadn't fucking painting.
Yeah,
he had a good weekend.
Wouldn't involve cocaine.
And it prompts,
you're showing,
I don't know.
There was two girls feel like there's some prostitution.
Well that that was,
he was arrested because it was an altercation in his room.
And these girls,
like,
I guess that he filmed them sucking his dick on his phone and they wanted the
money.
But I wish I could have sat down with them and said,
Warren,
sometimes when you,
when a girl is like that and she's freaking out and they want a few extra
hundred and they'll leave,
he got up to do it because you're paying your,
yeah,
it's shitty and it's not part of the deal.
But you are,
if they want,
I want $10,000.
That's different bullshit.
It is bullshit.
It's a bad business practice demand to see her.
So maybe I'm confusing his story and I believe I am with Mike Tyson story cause
he was arrested in Phoenix and he had cocaine on him but is a long,
tall.
Yeah,
no this was this passable past and he lost his gig and because he played shoved
the woman or whatever know.
And um,
but there was an altercation between them and him and I've had that where you
can feel,
cause I don't drink so maybe have a better sense for it.
Like,
if you're drunk,
you might be fucking,
not thinking,
but you can feel when it's about to go to a weird place and a lot of times you
got to back out and be calm.
And you know what I mean?
Like I had to go on time,
we would just text dirty shit all the time.
And she was threatening like she didn't know who I was as a comedian,
so she was threatening to expose me for my dirty fantasies and none of them were
things that would be that they a little bit on,
slightly embarrassing,
but none of them were like Horace,
who's threatening to expose.
She wanted money.
What?
And I kind of said to her,
I'm like,
first of all,
everyone I know knows I'm a pervert.
Everyone that hears you on the radio,
she did well.
She would always call the radio.
All the people that,
oh,
she didn't know.
Yeah.
Like you have no idea the person you're actually talking to right now.
So I'm like,
do what you have to do.
But you've literally just made a fucking committed a felony through text.
You're trying to blackmail me for money,
a dope and show that.
Yes.
I'm like,
yeah,
but then she's like,
well I wouldn't do it,
but somebody would.
I'm like,
what?
Oh,
we're tempting to blackberry.
But I wasn't even mad at her,
but I said to her,
this is the point.
I said to her,
look,
why don't we both just talk tomorrow when we have clearer heads and whatnot.
Let's not fight.
I said,
let's walk away.
I didn't say you fucking cut cause sometime you got to.
Yeah,
I was pointing people on the,
but I said,
uh,
you got to give people an out once in a while and that's what Warren Sapp in
that moment probably
didn't do.
He was probably so angry.
Like fuck you bitch and fuck you.
And they're arguing instead of realizing I got a Gig and the cops are gonna show
up,
give her the out or I look,
I don't want to fight with you.
Let's calm down.
You wanted,
here's an extra 300 let's walk away and maybe we'll talk tomorrow and do it
again.
Then she thinks she might see some more money coming in tomorrow.
She might actually be amenable to month to not screaming.
So whatever.
I've also heard there was trainees at blackmailed rappers.
I want a $30,000 in the lobby.
I've heard stories of that.
Wow.
30,000 yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I've had a few trainings tell me that until like,
yeah,
you know,
this has been rappers or whatever,
that fucking got black by a girls.
They start freaking out in the lobby and the guy's like,
all right,
come back up.
And they want money.
Wow.
Being a rappers,
a lot of pressure,
man.
Peter Comic,
nobody cares what the fuck you do.
Being a rapper,
he's gotta be a motherfucker cause pressure because they're not meeting.
Oh the train age wise and stuff,
we're all over again.
If they're into the weird shit,
you can't show weakness,
you can't eat m and m can self deprecate.
But that,
that whole act,
that whole side of psychology is harder for those guys because it's seen as
weakness and it's always got to be you and partying with a fat ass girl and a
car.
And I came from nothing and now I'm the shit and fuck you.
And it's like damn soda from the bottom.
Now we're here.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
That's a catchy fucking tune.
I don't even allow the phone to ballroom modal hold too.
Oh boy.
Is that a good one?
Yeah,
it's a smart move.
Yeah.
It's a weird cultural,
it's a culture of machismo.
It's like one of the most macho forms of music ever and a lot of ways.
Right.
More than rock.
Cause they don't want anything.
They have ballads too.
But I would say,
but he got to do it.
It was shooting each other like the guys in rock were never knowing that and
being a culture of their friends were getting shot.
Right.
That's a difference.
They took it to a totally new place.
The rap game.
And especially Gangsta rap.
I mean they made like east coast,
west coast rivalries involve gunfights.
Yeah.
Like that shit never existed before.
And where was there ever a guy and in,
in rock and roll that was like openly,
like shook night.
There really wasn't Phil Spector.
There was as close as you calm and he wasn't a gangster.
He's just a fucking Kook in the Hendricks manager.
Hendrix had a manager that apparently according to a guy who was once one of the
roadies,
are there security guys,
whatever the fuck it was,
he just put out a book saying that he thinks that not only did the manager kill
Hendrix,
but he killed Hendricks girlfriend too.
He's dead,
I guess.
Yeah.
Hendricks girlfriend was,
she fell or was pushed off of a roof and Soho like right after Hendrix died.
And you know,
the idea was that she committed suicide or she knew too much and she was killed.
I doubt that he use what I would guess,
knowing nothing other than what you just said.
And she allowed to Hendricks to die because she was afraid of the cops or find
the drugs in the room.
So that was why Hendrix died because he could have been saved if you just call
the ambulance,
but she didn't.
So the manager probably say,
you know how much money you cost me?
You dumb fuck and throw off the roof if that's like,
like Fort Apache.
But when I Ella towards that kid off the roof,
it was probably like that.
That could have been the case.
The,
the book was arguing that Hendricks was leaving the manager and the manager had
a stranglehold on Hendricks for a bunch of stupid reasons.
And one of
them was that he had faked a kidnapping.
He had a kidnap Jimmy and then rescue Jimmy had some people kidnap him and then
he said,
look,
I rescued you.
You're going to be fine.
I talked to the mob guys and everything's going to be okay.
And this is what this guy who wrote the book,
um,
fight,
try to find that.
Jamie,
try to find,
it was really recent,
like within the last year or so,
this guy wrote this book and it was really fascinating.
I heard him being interviewed or read it.
I don't remember which,
but it's a pretty,
uh,
pretty interesting.
The theories at this guy puts forth,
isn't that you're alive now are dead.
I think the manager is dead too.
But the manager was a notorious criminal.
Undoubtedly a bad guy and they believe that he really did have Jimi Hendrix
kidnapped and then stepped in to save him,
you know,
to let them know,
you've been around loyalty to me,
I'm going to keep you from all these bad guys.
I want to kidnap you.
And you know,
that's a,
that's a crazy tactic to kill it,
to keep an artist and you're stable.
Yeah.
It's fairly brilliant though.
I mean if you've got a Hendrickson,
you're stable,
you know,
you want to,
you you got to pull out all stops.
Well I think he realized that,
I think he realized he probably signed them before he really hit.
And then once he really hit,
he's like holy Jesus Christ,
look what I got on my hands.
Only like the greatest rock and roll guy ever.
Yup.
So with this guy was saying,
yeah,
book ups or the man who saved Jimmy Hendrix from the Mafia.
Is that it?
Romance,
mob,
kidnapping and waterskiing mishap.
Maybe.
I don't,
I think that's just part of it.
Yeah.
Just look up Jimmy Hendrix.
Um,
manage your,
killed him.
Look up that and see if you find,
oh God,
it was sexist,
racist history of SNL.
Like just looked at that headline.
God Good God.
How about rolling stone?
Boy,
they shit the bed.
Yeah,
they did.
It's amazing.
They get to put the fucking Boston bomber on the cover.
That,
that was disgusting.
And then this new thing,
well it not just they put him on the cover,
they put him on the cover looking cute.
A glamor shot,
glamor shot looking cute and his new book.
Yeah.
Rock roadie.
Write claims that Jeffrey told him he plied Hendricks with pills and alcohol in
order to kill him and claim on the guitars.
Life Insurance.
Wow.
Yeah.
Who knows,
man.
I wonder if that,
I wonder if that um,
hotel room is still there with that hotel has gone.
I know they took down the one that we're,
Bobby Kennedy was killed.
The ambassador is gone.
Yeah.
They just took that down.
Put a school there or something.
What are the hotel still stands?
We'll get this bullet.
Who said,
I was in London the night of Jimmy's death.
We went around to Monica's hotel room.
Got a handful of pills and stuffed and when his mouth and port a few bottles of
red wine deep into his windpipe.
Well,
it doesn't,
doesn't that seem there would be like some sign of struggle if they that was
Hendrix doing,
there'll be like cuts on them or something.
Manager was allegedly word that Hendricks is about to sack him.
He had recently taken a life insurance policy of $2 million.
Hmm.
That's if that's true.
That's wild.
But Jeffrey is the beneficiary.
We had to do it.
Jenny was worth much more than him dead than alive.
Jeffery's quote,
it's telling.
Right.
That's son of a bitch.
Just gonna leave me if I lost my lose everything.
Oh Man.
I don't know about all that.
Yeah,
it's all hearsay.
Yeah.
Who knows?
It's also,
yeah,
this guy wants to sell a book and he wants to make money.
The guy's dead.
The guy can't defend himself.
Right.
Who the fuck knows?
Meanwhile,
we just spread that rumor such Jay.
That's how you do it.
But we did say allegedly,
allegedly,
I love saying that.
It's a good word.
Good word.
Protection.
A lawsuit.
Ooh,
boy,
you want to throw out that allegedly,
allegedly is always important.
It's a nice little buffer.
Then I think even when allegedly I wonder by the way off the total of the Saudi
before I forget Jones,
uh,
against uh,
on my God Anthony Johnson.
What do you think?
It's a good fight.
It's a very good fight.
It's um,
it's all about whether or not Johnson can get ahold of Joan's because Joan's is
very good at using his reach better than anybody ever.
He's the very best that utilizing reach and he's also very good at using
techniques to keep people at bay.
He used a straight arm all the time,
which is not good because he pokes guys in the arm in the I occasionally.
Um,
so he's got to make sure if he does do that,
he puts palm to the forehead,
fingers really pulled back,
make sure that the fingers are an issue cause it's a legit technique that comes
from weak tie and Moitai.
You're see a lot of that they push off and in a leg kick,
push off,
elbow push off punch.
But there's a lot of pushing off and there's,
you know,
because they're,
they're doing different than boxing whether utilizing all these other techniques
like kicks and elbows and knees and stuff.
So pushing off and then pushing into quenching all that is a like a valid part
of that style of striking.
And it's probably one of the most effective styles of striking Johnson's really
fucking good at Moy Thai.
He's got a really good Dutch kickboxing coach.
This Guy Henri Hooft who is the lead trainer,
the Blackzilians which is a Florida based crew that has a lot of high level
strikers come through.
Um,
Tyrone Spong trains there.
Alistair Overeem was training there for a bit and uh,
they have a lot of like big named guys like Niki holds skin is like a,
a a famous Dutch guy who fights and glory and a bunch of other guys come in
through there.
This is like a go cart Saki,
like real,
real high level guys.
And so they all trained in this one spot.
So Johnson is getting like super high level training and kickboxing like key.
There was pictures of him sparring with Rico Verhoeven.
Rico Verhoeven is the glory heavyweight champion of the world and kickboxing bad
motherfucker,
just like super technical kickboxer.
So if Johnson's in their sparring with that guy and a daily basis,
he's getting some super high quality striking training and Johnson has lethal
power.
He's really a fucking strong dude,
man.
He's a destroyer.
He said destroyer.
His power is ridiculous and it's incredible that this guy started off his career
in the UFC at one 70 and now he's at two oh five two oh five.
He's just smashing people.
Not only did he not lose power going up 35 fucking pounds of competition weight,
not even body weight.
Like there's a lot of guys like Hendrix,
they'll fight at one 70,
he'll get the two oh five easy,
uh,
in the downtime cause he just gets fad,
eats a lot of fucking wild pigs and shit cause nutty.
He's a nutty Texas guy,
but I'm rumble would get up to that in meat.
He's,
he's got 205 pounds of fucking meat on him.
So he went from one 70,
the weight cut to two oh five comfortable weight cut and just smashing people.
It's crazy.
And it's unprecedented.
No one's ever done it before,
right?
No one's ever like gone up.
Not just one way class but two way classes and been a legit threat to the world
title.
What are they fighting?
They are fighting in May.
That is uh,
may,
um,
what is the date?
23rd of May 23rd.
Come on down.
I may go for that one.
Man.
That's a good one.
Go down,
cuts,
come hang with us.
Tom Segura and um,
Ari should fear no.
Tom Score and Tony Hinchcliffe and I are doing the coffee at her with,
oh,
is that not MGM?
Yeah.
Okay.
Go out there.
The only thing I take off to do is to go see fights.
I take off or nothing else know.
It's awesome.
I mean that's the only hot,
that's a hobby I have is I like to go to UFC and watch.
Like that's my only leisure activity.
Well,
I tell people like one of the funnest times I ever had in Vegas was the time
where I didn't have a gig scheduled and it was you and me and red ban and um,
Bobby Kelly and uh,
and Anthony remember we all ways dice.
Bobby Kelly was there too,
right?
He was,
yeah.
Yes.
And uh,
we all went to see dice.
We all had a steak dinner.
Like,
man,
we had a good fucking meal in us who went down to the Riviera and watched the
show,
hung out with dice and dices all happy to see us.
We went backstage,
we're chilling in the green room.
We had a great fucking time.
It was a lot of fun.
That was a great fucking time.
It was really fun.
I was one of my funniest times ever in Vegas and it was also a time to sit like
an audience member and just laugh.
We were just laughing like idiots.
Why watched you and I,
but I went out there and I haven't said,
I think I told you,
you're just the first comedy show I sat through in years and I mean fucking
years.
And it was fun to watch.
It was really enjoyable.
I might've seen the end of Ari who I like and then I watched you and it made me
laugh and it was kind of fun just to watch somebody perform who I know in like
and,
and just enjoy it.
Like you said,
it's the audience.
Well I did the same to you and Austin,
I told you that you kind of changed my thinking about two things,
about the length of a set and also about too many Dick Jokes.
Cause I would go,
God damn,
I got too many fucking Dick Jokes,
man.
But I saw Norton killed,
killed 50 minutes nonstop barrage of Dick Jokes.
And I'm howling laughing and I'm howling and laughing and uh,
I remember thinking,
you know what?
I like that you just pound them for 50 minutes.
I was always like,
I gotta do at least an hour,
10 maybe an hour or 20.
I think an hour is my magic number.
Two an hour now about an hour.
That
seems to be like the magic number where people just get tired of listening to
you.
So what I do is I bring good guys on the road with me and the good guys do like
at least a half an hour.
So I'll either Hinchcliffe we'll do a half an hour or if I have Hinchcliffe and
Secura they'll each do like 20 minutes.
So there's a nice variety of looks and then I'll do like an hour and it's a
great show.
It's a big pack together fast.
But like when I go to see a movie,
I'm so happy with a kickass 90 minute movie.
That's good.
Yeah.
You don't have to give me a three hour movie,
man.
I don't need a lord of the rings.
Fucking,
I don't need to drag it.
That bitch out.
The one and a half hours is a good number,
you know?
So he's seeing you and you crush for 50 minutes.
It like put it in my head.
I was like,
you know what?
I really enjoyed that.
And as an audience member,
I would really enjoy that.
Thank you.
Yeah.
You know what it is?
It's like you just,
I go through my phases where I'm really filthy or I'm not as dirty.
It all depends on what I'm,
what's happening in my life,
but like when I'm single,
like I am now,
I'm dirtier because doing more dirty shit,
there's more stuff to report.
I get a special coming out Friday the 24th is why I'm in La and um,
I'm really happy with it.
Nobody leaves.
It's like you always have to say that about your latest project,
but I actually really liked this one and I'm already,
but I'm already moving on because I've got to drop all that fucking material and
it's an hour of stuff that I no longer talk about.
You know?
That's a really fun,
it's fun to do.
I,
I get scared every time I do it.
Every time I dropped my act and start all over again,
I get scared,
but it's really fun.
What is it?
What is it called?
Contextually inadequate.
Yeah.
Where'd that come from?
It was,
it was something about context.
I had originally wanted to call it context,
not included,
but I didn't like that as much and I just thought of like,
it's like my greatest fear is to be an adequate,
like I feel sexually inadequate all the time and contextually inadequate.
I'm afraid that what I'm saying is meaningless.
So it just tied in.
It just felt right because it's by two greatest fears.
So I put them together,
made media under special.
I hope it's good.
I know it's going to be good and Hilarious,
but I thank you.
But I like it.
Like he,
a lot of times you shoot something normally you like in hindsight like I'll like
something I shot like a year later,
but um,
you know,
now I'm like,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm really happy with this.
I'm happy with the pace of it.
I'm happy with it.
I talk about Cosby,
I talk about Anthony getting fired,
you know,
just a lot of shit that,
fell Hong knew that's,
that's so important because one of the things that happens,
a comics when they hold on their material,
two longs that they don't think like that anymore.
All the Peter Criss I do,
I have all four kiss solo albums as characters.
Oh,
that one just me,
I got age freely is chip.
I got fucking,
one of them is Edgar and one his uncle Paul.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
And those are just all on the sabbath cover.
It was Collins.
I did cause you would've put yourself on album covers and I had this guy,
uh,
put me on all the black sabbath records and it's just,
you know,
every time you refresh the page is a different image.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
They just all just all sabbaths records.
That is hilarious.
I gotta do some more though.
Is that picture from the last one was that you with uh,
your,
uh,
when you had a nose operation?
Yeah,
that was just one of my many apnea photos.
My fucking fat face.
Even Though v I hate the way that,
that there's no,
no.
Um,
you know,
mozzies first record.
Wow.
This is pretty cool man.
And it feels like it's me.
It feels like it's my,
my,
it's Jim norton.com and it's just really like his money was,
what I was going to say is,
um,
that for me at least doing new material is really important.
Like at the end of a cycle,
like,
so you've got a two year cycle.
For me it's like two years seems to be,
if I do a special every one year that it's just too rushed,
that I'm,
I'm not honing the material enough.
I'm not giving my perspective chance enough to grow on stage.
And it's like I'll,
I'll do way more than I need to in those two years and then I'll whittle it down
to what I really like when that time comes,
you know?
But then it forces me when I abandon it and start with new stuff,
my perspective is always refreshed.
I think as,
as a person you're constantly reevaluating things and looking at it and has a
standup,
you kind of have to be,
you have to always be looking for what's funny about something.
What's interesting that changes and your material changes to,
you know,
and fans have to realize too like,
you know I get so it's amazing like how much feedback you get.
That is exactly the opposite.
Like you'll get one guy will tweet or,
right,
hey man,
fucking Nora and go stuff is a topical.
It doesn't hold up.
And then you,
the next person will say fucking enough with the trainee jokes in sex jokes.
It's like,
well make up your mind motherfuckers,
what do you want?
I can't do it for you.
I can only do like what feels right.
And the reason I do a lot of topical stuff is aid interests me and beats.
Like I talk on the radio every day.
That's what's on my mind.
It's like when you're fucking reading the paper every day and you're talking
about stuff every day you're formulating opinions because you're talking about
something long form for,
it's six minutes or 10 minutes and then you just start getting an idea about it
and you create something and yeah,
but the people that are like really wacky,
hardcore fans,
they'd get upset if you talk about something on the radio and then that becomes
a bit,
yeah,
talk about the on the roof.
We were newer.
They don't know what they want because the,
the,
the criticism is again,
50% say this,
50% say that.
I think it's even more than 50% say they like being in on the creative process.
Like,
oh,
I remember when you first brought that up,
but those are the people that are just looking to complain.
Yeah.
No matter what you do,
there's going to be some people that are just looking to be upset.
And there's some people that just want to get your attention.
They just want you to notice them.
They do.
And I actually wrote about that when Lindy West and I had that debate about rape
jokes afterwards I,
she was getting like a lot of rape comments,
hope you raped and killed and you know,
she was wrote a big blog about how it was all this,
this rape threats.
And then I wrote something for Xo Jane,
which I,
you know,
I didn't think they would legit rape threats.
They would like,
if we've been talking about drunk driving,
I said people would have fucking run.
I hope you're killed by a drunk driver.
It's one of those things that people just want to be heard.
They want to say stole the worst thing they can say,
I hope you get raped.
It's pretty much the worst thing.
It's like walking into a room and just screaming really loud.
He goes,
what was that?
We noticed you let you get wanted.
Well,
you know what man,
there's always going to be people that are just looking to get upset and there's
always gonna be people that are looking to piss people off.
You know it was if they think they can push your buttons and trolls,
like anonymous trolls online,
taking them into account as an actual legit threat,
you have no idea what you're doing with it might be a legit threat,
but it also might be some 13 year old kid who's a dickhead.
I think the majority of them,
this is what I love when they criticized material or they criticize what you're
doing,
whether we have been talking about opie and Anthony and a lot of people,
he's not be telling the truth like,
what do you want me to say?
What do you mean you're not telling the truth?
He's what?
A lot of a lot of these guys just want me to go on the radio and motherfuck Oop,
and they think that's what's being honest.
They think that that's what I should do.
Meanwhile they're posting under anonymous names.
It's like you fucking cowards.
You fucking afraid for everybody to see who you really are.
Cowards sitting in your house,
demanding other people do shit that you would,
you don't have the moral courage to say your name,
go fuck yourself.
But they think that's what honesty is like.
That's what they want.
And it's like,
if I don't give them that they instead of realize it may be,
that's not where the truth lies for me.
They think I'm not being honest.
Yeah,
but you're evaluating the minds of retards,
right.
Way To put it.
He's really dopey people for logic and reasoning.
There's just a bunch of people that are just content.
No matter what you do.
And if you really concentrate too much about what they're saying,
you're going to get crazy.
It's like you're,
you're taking in crazy input and this,
but there are times where they're right and then like with my standup or other
things and then criticized I,
and this is why they annoy me.
It's like,
it's like,
hey dummies.
I've actually given you guys credit when you're right.
I've really meant it when I've said,
there are times when they say things that are really smart and intuitive and
they fucking nail.
One of my shitty habits or my verbal crutches or what a hand,
they make a lot of very valid points.
And then I'll read that they theorize something about the radio show and it's
like,
oh my God,
that I give you any,
it's way too much credit.
Well,
you see what you're saying.
The problem with what you're saying is they,
you're saying they as if they're all like one collective unit that has a vote
and that's your side.
And there's a bunch of fuck heads out there and there's a bunch of really cool
people out there too.
And sometimes the really cool people,
they disagree with you and they have a good point.
And there's just a way to do it where it's like,
you know,
I noticed that he relies on this a bit too much.
It gets,
uh,
it gets a tad tiresome or it gets really tiresome.
You could even say it gets really tiresome and maybe you don't like hearing that
it stings,
but maybe that's what you need to hear.
But there's a difference between that and someone has just a dummy who also gets
the same amount of voice.
Like you know,
you're on Twitter and someone's reaching out to you on Twitter.
If you read a dummy's words,
you know he got to you just like the smart guy show it to you.
They all just,
they're all,
they're all receiving,
you're receiving,
although that data in your brain,
it's just,
you've got to decide like,
okay,
what kind of a person am I taking this advice from?
What kind of a person my receiving this criticism from?
Is he a fucking idiot or is this a cool person who just disagrees with me?
And there's two different types of people out there when it comes to things that
are conflict.
There's cool people that you can get involved with,
conflicts with,
where you work out each other's differences.
And then there's cots
and that's the,
the fine art of anonymous internet interaction.
Like you can be anonymous and still not be a cut.
I,
and that's the thing is that,
that's what irritates me about that culture.
It's like my,
the public email,
the real Jim Norton at Gmail is for people to contact me.
I'm not once,
have I ever gotten an email from somebody that was reasonable.
If it's nasty,
I'll answer you nasty or I'll ignore you.
But I've never gotten one that was,
you know,
and again guys,
not,
you guys had medication,
you fucking slow down with the eight paragraphs,
you know.
But if you send me an email,
go look,
this is what I don't like about the show and I feel you guys are doing this too
much.
I really do read it and I really do listen to what you say.
A lot of times I don't agree with it and there's times where I write you back,
but I'm not that irrational where somebody will be critical if just don't be a
dick.
Right?
Like you can't say to me like,
you know what I mean?
Fucking show stinks and an your content and then you don't respond.
And they go say he can't take criticism.
It's like we can not exactly being fucking,
you know,
you're not contacting me,
calling someone a cunt is not the act of a friend.
So you know,
you're not writing me an email and just go and look man.
I think you guys are disloyal to and has a lot of loyalty issues.
Yeah.
It's like how much more loyal,
what do you want me to be to Anthony?
Like I love Anthony.
Like how can I express to you?
Like that's not enough for them.
At first they were like,
well you know,
you're not saying you're loyal to Anthony.
I'm going to Anthony show and then that's not enough.
And like,
well it does it say he loves Anthony and goes on to show what would you like me
to do?
Anthony and I are fine with how we treat it.
Just like,
what do you want?
Sometimes I think that they just don't know what they want and I wish you would
express to me what you want.
Send me an email.
That makes sense.
Unmedicated and I really will read it and try to accommodate you like I do.
I do want the fucking fans happy.
They don't seem to get that.
It's like,
I really do like,
you know,
I stand out and meet everybody and I don't charge for fucking photos.
You do the same thing.
I've seen you do it.
How much more can I say to fans?
I appreciate what you do and I do appreciate your input.
Then standing there like a fucking dumb just bucket.
I don't charge for anything.
Most of you don't buy things on the way out.
And I always thank you for coming and like what are you want me to do is suck
your Dick in the parking lot with a gun there.
Most people are cool,
right?
So you're freaking out about a small percentage.
They used to just ignore.
I'm actually,
I might even freak out,
like I'm not even,
I'm a little hyper now cause I'm drinking this fucking gasoline you gave me.
It's very good.
Caveman coffee.
Delicious.
And uh,
but it does hype me up,
but I'm not even angry at them.
It's like some of them are really funny and somebody in the mean ones are really
funny dudes.
And it's a guide.
You're fucking,
you know more about the show then to be this dumb at this moment.
Like you know more about what we do and about our interactions with each other
and it'd be a dope at this moment,
but I'm not even that mad at them.
It's like some of them just are hilarious.
Well,
and it's also,
they're not realizing that you're just a person is for some reason when you
think of someone as being a famous community and I'm thinking I'm being way out
there and New York
or wherever the fuck they are at the moment you're tweeting at them and they're
tweeting back.
Like that doesn't even seem real to a kid.
If you're an 18 year old kid and you're living in Cleveland and a year you get
on your iPhone and you're like,
fuck you,
you just bucket to you and then you're like,
I didn't say anything to you asshole.
You're like,
Jim Norton really tweet at me like they didn't,
doesn't even seem real.
I love,
I love Gail going back at them and having fun with them.
And I liked sometimes being a dick and then knowing that they're just going to
start fighting with other people and it's out of my hands.
It's kind of fun.
Well,
I do enjoy going to people's Twitter pages when they all day long or in
legitimate fights.
Like one of the things I noticed this group that likes to call themselves social
justice warriors or they get disparagingly referred to as social justice
warriors as a bunch of these people that I follow and some of them that even I'm
on a block list,
can't believe that I am too.
I think I know that list.
Somebody sent me that because you send out in Cindy Arie things and,
and,
and in and they're weak culture of I don't want to read what upsets me.
Yeah,
I mean jokes.
So No.
Yeah,
it jokes are bad for our culture.
Um,
but my point being I like to go to their pages because some of them,
their entire like timeline is them fighting with people like in these horrible
like insult laden back and forth conversations and there's that old expression
that if you go outside and you run into an asshole,
you probably just ran into an asshole.
But if you go outside and everybody you meet is an Asshole,
it might be you,
right?
You're the common denominator.
It might be you.
Yeah.
Like give your Twitter feed is just constant complaining about everything in the
world and then arguments with people that are disagreeing with you that it end
up in horrible insults.
Like maybe it's you,
maybe it's you,
like maybe you don't realize you're transmitting a signal and that signal is
super conti and what you're getting back to super country data,
you know,
and you'd think it's the whole world.
The world sucks.
And Look,
I'm getting rape threats and I'm getting all these horrible harassment baby.
Maybe that's what's,
maybe you send out a real shitty flag.
You,
you fly a shitty flag and shit comes back your way and people respond to it and
in a shitty way and they don't like it.
Like if somebody insults you publicly and then you insult them back,
they get all the stuff like what are you picking on me?
And it's like when Norton attack to blogger,
you're a heckler,
you've heckled me online.
You had mentioned me.
So I see it.
You basically,
they will usually say like,
Jim,
I'd like to walk up to you and go fuck you and your face and then walk away
without you saying anything.
But what do you should,
you should do that to your fans.
Yeah.
Let them say,
dude,
you don't even love your fans.
They are animals.
They really are good though.
But they're just the things they tolerate me saying,
I was on stage in Denver recently and the biggest response I got was doing chip
and uncle Paul.
I'm threatening them.
The lesson you're like reminiscing about,
I always find a young guy and just talk about like,
yeah,
Hey,
remember when you was
a baby?
And they fucking love knowing that I'm going to talk about molesting this man.
Well it's that character,
that code.
It's allows you to do things that are totally unacceptable.
Normally my favorite thing to do in the world,
there's nothing if I could literally doing chip and uncle Paul and I agree with
all that stuff.
It's so here's why it's so much fun cause it's like I know he's playing the bad
guy.
Like how many you get to explore that fucking horrible side of like when we're
doing a story about like a fucking priest or a molester.
Just to know that like uncle Paul can step in and go in any direction.
It's so much fun cause you know as a man you got to go on.
It's terrible.
That's wrong.
But that's not funny to say.
But it is to me.
How long has uncle Paul been around for?
Well he started,
uncle Paul started is,
I've been doing character for years in relationships long before I did them on
the radio,
I didn't to annoy my girlfriends and he'd be,
he was uncle Larry many years ago.
There was Roger Davis or Roger d and this is long before chip,
there was Roger and Roger had a brother Lester who was burned in a fire and
unless you've got a whole time like all storyline,
Lester was burned everywhere but his knees and his,
until he would always wear knickers to show off his legs.
It was a whole thing.
And Uncle Roger,
I know uncle,
uncle Larry and then it merged into chip who my girlfriend hated so much and
chip became the fucking cause they would chip,
would embarrass people.
I did had literally before I ever thought I'd do on the radio,
I would be out with girlfriends and embarrass them by doing that.
Like we,
I'll just be making bad jokes in the cab and my girlfriend,
I,
you know,
a Jen and even grow up and go home.
We just go,
just shut the fuck up.
It's not funny.
And it made me so happy.
And what's,
this is what would drive Jenny crazy.
He'd be like a really nice steakhouse and the way it would come over and she
would order like the salmon and then chip just goes,
how much is that?
And would ask the way there and she was like,
do you know how humiliating it is that people think I fucked that guy.
People think I'm fucking this guy.
And that's where they come from.
That visceral reaction.
It was real like I was who was doing one night that she all I would do,
I would,
do you know how I,
Edgar's one I don't do as much because Edgar is the moment that tiny mouth,
he just go room and decree knowers and that's his thing.
But he had a brother Eugene and Eugene was always telling her that like,
you know,
you need to get right with Lord.
And he would always tell him she was garbage and a whore.
She was telling my girlfriend she was a whore and she was not worthy and crying.
I'm crying.
But I,
what happened was my girlfriend at the time,
who's now my best friend,
she,
my extra girlfriend from years ago,
she hated Eugene so much and I meet,
it wasn't even funny anymore and we would do it and she would dig her
fingernails into my face.
She dug her nails into my face cause I think Eugene had his spot.
It's true
and I'm,
I'm crying.
He would,
it was,
it was such a visceral reaction from her as I stopped doing Eugene,
who,
she caught me dirty texting with another girl.
She fucking,
I told you,
I only told us it wasn't even a girl.
I have a fuck.
It was just a girl.
I told you my dirty,
intriguing.
It was a girl.
I was like,
I'll pay you 500 baby.
I fucking,
I'm such an addict.
I would save my conversations to jerk off to write and I hit the wrong button by
button and I fucking printed it.
Dude,
I fucking printed it.
So she wakes me up one morning,
she goes,
Jim,
wake up.
And I knew I was in trouble.
So she found these things and she knew I hadn't fucked the girl,
but it was a real strain on the relationship.
So as I swear to you as one of the ways of making amends to her,
I stopped doing Eugene.
I killed off Eugene Mellencamp because she,
cause I do a baby boy character named Jelly who she liked who's jelly.
I don't do jelly published too embarrassed.
He's just a little boy.
But she thought he was really cute and uncle Paul would always molest jelly.
Fucking and chip was so stupid.
Chip would always drop jelly off and uncle Paul's house.
No,
it was a whole fucking inner world.
Ah.
So Ah,
yeah,
chip would be like,
what if uncle Paul's a good guy,
he's helping out and she has so and she would do,
would drive a crazy,
so silly,
but it was just a fun way to be.
And uh,
she reacted so strongly.
So,
um,
I,
I've said before,
I don't want it,
like I am animating them now and I'm in a point now with them where I haven't
introduced them.
We're working on it.
You're going to do an actual show with these pilots.
Oh yeah.
But this is after years of people telling me to do it.
Well you,
what are you going to do it on?
I don't know yet,
but it's going to be on something on Netflix.
I'm not,
they got bill Burke cartoon and they,
I don't think they're interested and I don't want to,
I want to do it online somewhere.
I don't think I'll be able to monetize it.
I have a six minute pilot.
I have a second five minute episode,
uh,
where the audio is all taped already.
And I'm looking at what they call animatronics now,
which is to very basic animation.
It's like a storyboarding that moves.
So it doesn't really look like the characters,
but they have,
they're just showing you the motion they're going to be in and where they are.
But I got to see chips face animated.
I have,
I see what the character looks like and it's getting to where I'm happy with it.
You know,
cause again,
different levels of automation or it's expensive shit.
It's like two grand a minute.
So both of these things are costing me like 20 grand to do total,
which is all right.
That's not that bad.
If it's an investment and it's mine and I fucking own it,
but you know to get the animation,
that's amazing.
It's like five grand a minute and it's like I'm,
I'm not funding that mice.
So these are,
these are a fucking a,
it's a beginning and where it will go from here depends on how people respond to
it.
If they think it's funny and they like it,
they might go,
that's cool,
but we want this,
we want that.
But I really a,
I want to do something with it.
So I've gotten a lot of the characters in the first one and in the second one I
have a couple of the characters and I think people will like it.
But I literally just did it cause you have to years and years of people telling
me to do this stuff,
but it's the most fun I have on the road.
This is nothing.
I can't listen to Jim Norton.
I really like it.
He was a kid.
I would always have like a these weird flake.
I would detach from Jim Norton and we would fantasize.
Like I had this little baby biz fantasy of me when I was five.
Me and Jimmy Robinson were friends.
Jimmy Robinson was a boy and a Cape who was me.
He was Jim Norton indicate but me and Jimmy Robinson hated Jimmy Norton.
Who is this weird separation between like,
I don't know who I was.
I was just this guy and I,
you know,
it was five or six and Jimmy Robinson was really cool and good looking and he
was five or six and then he looked like he was me.
But he wrote a tricycle and had a fucking Cape and we just Cim Norton,
which fucking Shit.
So I've always had this weird detachment.
So I don't like listening to myself any more than anybody else does right now on
coffee.
But I like watching,
I like listening to uncle Paul or chip cause they don't,
they don't sound like me.
So I'll go back and listen to fucking chip.
And I laughed like I've never heard it before cause I don't remember saying it.
I mean I remember doing it,
but I don't,
in those moments you're not fucking paying attention.
So in those moments you are really thinking like that guy.
Oh it's all,
yeah,
it's,
it's never thought through ever.
And I'll listen sometimes and remember it and I'll listen to it.
Like somebody who's like,
oh yeah,
no,
you really are thinking in that
mindset but it's fine.
But it's fun to do and that's why I'm always interested like what?
I'm uncomfortable acting somewhere.
And again,
I know the different between standing with Clive Owen with a bunch of people
playing doctors,
that's a real situation.
So just talking to my fucking,
you know,
Dumbo fucking friends on the radio and Bob Kelly's there,
you know it,
there's no pressure with your buddies.
But it's almost like why is one so comfortable where there's,
there's zero planning in it and it's just going to be,
you're talking about whatever you think of for five minutes and you know,
it has to be funny and you know,
it has to move the story along.
Why is that not scary at all?
But this is so something is interfering or thing to kind of bring it back.
But that's the most fun I have is doing that shit.
That's it.
So you've been doing these characters like for a long time?
Yeah.
I brought him to the radio over time.
They became the radio over time,
but they were,
they existed long before radio.
They existed in my personal life as just a fun way to be.
There's so many.
The one like my ex girlfriend was the best and got,
I'll see her tonight.
She's fucking awesome.
Um,
Jennifer,
I'd never given her name before,
but we,
I've talked to about,
her name is Jennifer Carmody and she has a podcast.
She's really a funny person and she,
um,
she's the one,
she fucked the characters.
Like she fucked chip and uncle Paul and Jane is hilarious and she,
ah,
she fucks suddenly suddenly was one I never done suddenly was one who was just
Dominique would drool a lot and he would lick the side of her face and her neck
and she hated.
Suddenly I,
he was kind of retarded,
but he never made it to the radio.
Some things don't translate.
They just thinks you're doing your personal life.
Tell me what kind of a cast or you have in your brain,
how many people are in there?
There was at one point with Jen and then Jen,
the reason she's working on this animation with me because literally her and my
manager Jonathan and club Soda Kenny have dealt with these people in their
personal lives more than any of you have ever heard them on the radio.
There wasn't one point with Jen.
There was,
of course it was chip and there was jelly and it was a Edgar Mellencamp and
Eugene Mellencamp and I did kill off Eugene.
There was,
um,
uncle Paul.
There was,
she remembered,
uh,
Sheldon who was a,
there was another one called the Sushi kid who was just a guy who can't talk
like Ritzville Watch,
but like who she,
uh,
and talked all about Sushi Sushi kid.
And then it was fucking suddenly who drooled a lot and always go.
But there was a lot of,
a lot of these characters had no depth to them.
And that's why I didn't bring them to the radio.
They were only funny contextually in the relationship cause Jen got them and I
got them.
So there was no,
they would be one trick ponies on the radio.
Uh,
there'll be get all that.
He just felt like Jimmy [inaudible] and he would like lick her pussy bad or
liquor thighs,
which is closer out to,
there was no way to translate that.
So one night she fucked ship and uncle Paul and suddenly,
and she said chip was the worst.
Fuck what's always made me like she's uncle Paul was probably the best of the
three.
So while you're fucking there,
you're in these characters.
Only that time as a goof,
she suck chips.
Dick wants to chip.
Chip came in one time,
chip came in one time,
I said,
cool.
And he was like,
fucking Jedi.
Call my bomb like you've put,
Bobby was in Montreal,
I bombed at the festival and she felt bad.
She blue chip,
she was a fuck.
She was all areas.
Um,
and who else was there?
There was fucking a,
at one point there's one called the gossip kid,
which I know he was black and I don't do him anymore.
Yay.
He was just the one that would kind of sum up.
He almost worked like it was not based on this cute way before I ever saw a
fucking,
they,
uh,
we were Harold Perrineau when he did Oz,
the guy in the wheelchair,
the black guy.
We kind of narrate.
That's what the gossip kid did.
He would just narrate,
you know,
like,
you know what I mean?
I heard Uncle Paul,
you know,
I heard a bit stuck uncle Paul's Dick.
It was like that and she made her laugh.
The gossip kid was one of the favorites we would do.
But then our relationship ended years ago,
so I don't do the gossip kid anymore,
but the gossip kid with some,
the characters.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
That's what I'm going to do too.
I forgot about him until recently.
I started doing them again to another friend of mine actually.
He was like,
that's fucking funny.
Did.
He comes out on on the radio once in a while to he'll just do it like,
God,
people will always hit me.
Go,
who is that bitch?
And that's the,
that's that,
that's that character.
But I haven't gone into great depth with it.
Jimmy,
you need to do a podcast just by yourself.
Just by yourself talking to different guests.
Just you and a guest.
I don't know if it would be,
he wouldn't be fucking beautiful.
People hear me so much on the radio.
Maybe if I didn't have radio.
Um,
I hear you.
You know what I mean?
People would get bored of me.
I think that they wouldn't get bored of you had a podcast.
I guarantee you,
you would reach a lot of people.
And even if you only did it once a week,
would it be a bad idea to have something in the back burner?
Who the fuck knows what's going to happen with series?
That's true.
I mean,
they're doing well right now,
but the Internet is a strange thing.
The Internet is going to be in cars.
It's going to happen within the next decade,
within the next decade.
It's going to be real hard to justify paying for satellite radio cause there's
going to be some,
someone's going to figure out programs that you could do that mimics satellite
radio and they become native apps on your car whether we talked about it before,
whether it's Pandora or some new thing that we even know where
they have that stitcher app now on your,
your car.
A lot of Ford cars where you can download podcasts directly from the thing you
have favorites,
you save them so you can have like,
like stations that you could click on,
you can go to different podcasts.
All that stuff is,
you know,
it's going to be hard to compete with that.
Yeah,
I think you're right and I think he had less than a decade,
I think.
I think it'd be a lot sooner than that before the cars have it.
No,
they definitely going to have it less than a decade.
But I mean like how much more time to seriously like I like serious.
I liked.
I like switching to the channels and listening to different music or listening
to Howard.
Then listening to you guys and listening to a,
I listened to two.
Um,
it's Ron and Ron and Fez,
good shows and uh,
there's a bunch of different things you can listen to.
There's a lot of different classic vinyl station to play.
Cool music.
You know.
Ozzy's boneyard is my favorite station anywhere.
Yeah.
There's some great law.
What does it last tracks?
What does that one,
there's deep tracks.
Deep tracks is like real obscure songs.
Hope he likes that one a lot too.
Yeah.
I think he probably goes more deeper music than I do.
I,
I don't,
I don't listen,
I don't listen to most of the mutation.
She said Ozzy's boneyard and occasionally hairnation I'll listen to it a 70
channel.
But like when you,
when you really think about it,
the benefit of the Internet is a bunch.
There's a bunch of different benefits.
But one of the big ones is you can be anywhere.
You could be in a parking garage.
Like it's really annoying when you're listening to a good show.
And then you'd go into a tunnel and it stops because your satellite connections
count.
But with cellular connections you can get a cellular connection way more places.
You can get a cellular connection underground,
you can get it in parking lot structures.
You're getting a lot of different places that you can't get radio.
And also like what I was driving on Topanga Canyon yesterday and a fucking sunny
day and satellite was cut now.
Oh really?
Yeah,
it's just trees.
Just the trees.
Like there's areas of Topanga where you're,
you're driving through the canyon and there's just this canopy of trees overhead
and it just blocks out the satellite.
That's Piss real quick.
I gotta I guess.
Definitely I'll be right back.
And let's promote Jimmy's special.
That is on Epix,
uh,
coming up real soon.
[inaudible] um,
contextually inadequate.
April 24th on Epix and epics is the same network that was airing deep web on May
31st,
which is,
uh,
our friend Alex winter who was here yesterday or the day before yesterday and a,
so epics is doing some fucking cool shit and Jim has already done one special on
epics already.
So this'll be his a second special on,
uh,
everybody asks you about tonight at the uh,
ice house is sold out,
sorry,
pitches.
And then the next gig that we have that's a big one is in New York that's sold
out too.
That's up the,
what is it called?
Um,
what's the name of that joint?
What is it?
The grand ballroom.
The grand ballroom ballroom in New York City.
So the next gig that I had that's available that actually has tickets available
is the car theater at MGM.
And that's on the 22nd.
So that's a,
and then we'll,
we'll be doing some ice house shows in town between now and then.
And definitely the comedy store.
And one of the things we started doing it,
the comic stores,
that belly room.
Have you done the belly room?
I've done the uh,
you know what maybe I have,
what's the,
uh,
the one that everybody,
the original room in the other,
and I get it to the original room is the downstairs room that seats about,
I guess like one 50.
And the main room seats,
I think all full seats.
400 people.
I've never done it.
And then the belly room only seats like 80 or something like that.
It's a tiny ass room.
Like if you want to stuff people in there,
you might get 90.
And it's amazing.
I did it last night for this,
uh,
Jeremiah Watkins,
young kid out here has this,
a show that he used to do called Thunderpussy where it was like a podcast that
he did it,
but a lot of people didn't want to do it on a podcast.
I just want to do it on a regular show.
So they stopped doing it as a podcast and now maybe stopped.
I don't know if he'd stopped.
Yeah,
but he does.
He gives does both.
But stand up on the spot is what they call it in someone.
The people yell out topics and you're forced to make jokes or make fun of them.
Oh Wow.
Cool.
And everybody knows that's what it is.
So they know you might stumble a little bit and it might be you,
you're going to have subjects that you just don't have anything.
Oh,
that's awesome.
But you're forced into that situation.
We're trying to make comedy and I've come up with a bunch of bids because of it,
because we've done it like three or four times now and you come up with like,
you know,
you might do 15 minutes,
you might get three minutes out of it.
We're like,
wow,
this is actually got potential.
Hope they're good topics,
girl,
Fort Shaw,
get out of my way.
There's a lot of that.
What does,
what's a really hard,
when it,
they throw out,
uh,
economics.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
Someone,
someone yelled out,
space travel,
you know,
economic space travel.
This is,
but you're always going to have like,
you know,
they don't know who knows?
You might,
you might like in that moment,
like someone could yell out economics and you have nothing,
or you can be in the right frame of mind at the right moment and you just have
this idea and then you just run with it on stage and people start laughing
hilariously hysterically and you're like,
oh,
there is something in that.
I didn't even consider that.
But you're forced into this like you're forced to to run,
you're forced to figure out how to run.
Right,
right,
right.
Forced to figure out how to swim.
You just thrown into the water.
You figure it out.
I liked that.
I did one similar that Paul Provenza has one.
It was,
it was always his call list set list and there was some really hard weird things
on there,
but that was kind of fun to go up there and just explore it and see,
see where you go with it and where your mind works and that's really fun shit to
do.
Yeah,
it's fun.
It's a good way to start new material to like just to get the beginnings of a
new bit or the idea of a new bit like you've got to trick yourself.
I think Ari and I were talking about this once.
If you do too many gigs,
if you don't live your life enough,
absolutely right,
like sometimes you just,
you have too much,
too much gigs and not enough life,
nothing to fetal.
If a bear was saying that the same thing.
Actually bear was saying that,
you know,
sometimes he needs to do things and that's why I think he got in the helicopter
flying and he actually was doing
a bit on helicopter flying.
He's decided,
well I'll fucking actually take some lessons.
And then in taking glasses he actually want to be enjoying it.
Well that's,
you know,
it's funny you say that because that's another part of me not wanting to be such
a piece of shit any more sexually because you,
you,
you be,
you feed on only the same thing and there's nothing new coming into my life.
There's no new input.
So there's stuff I talked about on the radio,
which is topical and then there's that and it's like,
no man,
it's a whole life out there that you're not enjoying and living.
And you know,
again,
I'm not crying the blues.
I make good money.
I have a nice apart,
like I've been very lucky in comedy,
but it's like there's so many fun things to do.
Like,
just go out with someone somewhere without a goal of sexual whatever,
or just,
you know,
go away for the night to a little dumb town and go shopping or just do some
fucking dumped shit that people do.
That's fun.
That's relaxing and normal and normal human beings do not be itching,
not be edging it fucking hours.
Dude,
I'm telling you,
it fucks me up so much.
It's like,
it's like this weird,
uncomfortable,
scared feeling I get when I'm done too.
Like I get very scared like I'm exposed man.
You know what I mean?
Like,
Oh God,
she's married a fucking husbands going to find out.
I talked to that girl to jerk me off.
I gave him a 500 man,
but a fucking husbands going to shoot me if he finds out like [inaudible] you
like that I do in a moment,
but as soon as you come,
boy you stopped liking it.
You know what I mean?
Oh God,
this is fun.
I'm going to get killed.
It's really,
I'll fucking load coming out really brings you right back to reality.
Isn't it funny though,
that part of being like a funny guy.
I like the way you are is,
is dependent upon like impulsive behavior and thoughts.
Like there's something about like the actual creation of a bit like an Improv
line,
a hilarious Improv line.
A lot of that is like impulsive things.
Sure.
Yeah.
It's somebody will yell something or you just think of something you say it.
Even though if you thought it through,
you might not say it,
will you tweet it?
Which is why guys get in trouble.
Um,
you know what I mean?
It is that you're right,
that impulsive thinking that this is the thing that makes you great is also the
thing that will eventually ruined you.
My favorite tweet that someone should never done is that woman who was working
for some publicity firm or something like that and she flew to Africa.
I'm sure it's just like on my way to Africa.
Hope I don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white,
lol.
And then she lands and it's a national fucking scandal and she lost her job.
I mean,
what are the odds that anyone's going to read that tweet and decide to like go
after you?
You know what it is.
They were like,
Hey let's get this publicist.
But what she was saying Justine Sacco and at least a stupid thing to say,
but what she's probably saying is,
hey,
white people like it.
So sometimes there might even be a statement about how it's unfair that only the
black guys are,
I don't think she meant like fuck black people or do you think she did?
I don't know.
I think she was just trying to be funny.
Maybe.
I think she just saw it choose being funny going to Africa.
Hope I don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white.
I think she was just being an asshole just shouldn't be.
I mean I don't mean an asshole in a bad way,
but you're funny.
Yeah.
Funny.
Being goofy and just being an ass.
Well that's something that a comic would say.
I mean tell me a colic wouldn't say that.
Absolutely lot of comics would say that.
The thing is that they're getting,
I've had a wide,
a weird thing too,
cause you're not people getting fired for tweets.
And it uprooted our radio show obviously.
Um,
you know,
it's very frustrating and it's stupid.
But then I hear these guys who sent these tweets to,
to a curt Schilling's daughter was curt Schilling,
the pitcher and those a big,
it was a red sox pitcher.
He pitched,
he had the bloody sock and he tweeted something about his daughter,
a pitching in a college game.
So these anonymous,
these fucking cowards,
they tweet this stuff about his daughter that's really nasty.
And some of it,
he said it might've been illegal because it was sexual stuff too.
I don't know.
But they both were up there.
They found out who they were and they were both fired from their jobs or one
was,
and I was happy that they got fired because I didn't like them.
But I had a real dilemma because the emotional part of me is like,
good fuck these scumbags.
And then the other part of me is you shouldn't be firing people because they say
dumb shit.
But then I'm like,
okay,
say you were a doctor and you tweet,
I hate Jews.
Like there's the hospital and I have the right to go.
We don't want you working for us.
Are Jewish clientele would legitimately not feel comfortable having you operate
on like I'm just kind of in a quandary about it cause I don't know how to feel
about any of it.
No.
Like I'm such a,
I'm always like,
whatever you say you shouldn't get in trouble for.
Uh,
I mean there is a penalty to speak,
but you shouldn't get fired for doing dumb jokes.
But what if you were,
say if you're working with a guy,
like say you're in an office and the guy shares the office is a small amount of
people.
There's like three or four people in the office and you guys work in and out
together day in,
day out.
And one of you you find out is sending really mean tweets to a baseball player's
daughter.
Really evil,
vicious shit for no reason.
Like just an asshole doesn't know the girl.
He's just an asshole.
Why the fuck would you want to work with that?
Right,
that's the truth.
So why can't you find that guy?
Because that guy is negative to the environment of the office because this is,
and,
and I like,
I'm happy he got fired again emotionally.
Right.
But,
but,
but the part of me that contradicts that is going.
Yeah.
But yeah,
that was an obvious one.
All right.
The guy was a con,
but then there's the ones where people are just going for a joke.
Like that lady.
Yeah.
And then she gets fired.
So like who makes the determination?
Like that's what tries to be crazy.
I don't know how to feel about it.
Like I,
I,
we felt disloyal to my own point of view because I was so,
I was like,
fuck those guys.
You know?
And I'm,
I'm telling on myself by saying it.
But I mean like I,
I don't know,
I just had a bit of a dilemma with this one lately.
Well,
she was interviewed with a,
I forget what blog.
Excuse me.
I hate when I keep doing that until I get the same thing.
I sat the defendant fucking child rape child.
No,
I just want not.
I have it in there.
It's this,
yeah,
it's a coffee.
It's the butter.
So the butter in the coffee and she was talking about how it essentially
uprooted her entire life.
Like she landed in Africa and didn't even realize what was going on.
Slept,
you know,
probably took a sleeping pill.
It's a long flight.
Woke up,
didn't even realize what she had caused.
And then she had lost her job and people hated her.
They
were,
people were having conversations about her on CNN and they were calling her a
piece of shit and it got ugly,
really ugly.
And she kind of went into hiding and then she got a gig somewhere else.
I don't remember where her Gig is,
nor would I mentioned.
And if I do did know it,
but she,
you know,
she recovered,
she recovered and got back on track.
But she's made a careless joke.
She thought she was being funny.
She thought she was being silly and she didn't think that that many people are
gonna listen to it or read it.
And the intent in what she's doing is different than what those guys saying to
Kurt Shaklee.
But then there's the thing where you know,
supports guys,
you like you said,
you think they're immune.
Like cause people yell stuff all the time.
It's sports figures fucking drop dead a Rod,
you suck.
You'd fucking,
it's like,
what's the like who's to say what's right?
And that's where I'm kind of just whatever,
I don't even know what I'm saying y'all.
I'm just kind of know it's confusing me a little bit.
And I think the sports guys,
if they're saying something that's absolutely mean and vicious and nasty and you
don't want them representing your organization.
So if you have an organization,
if you have a team or if you have ESPN,
it makes sense to me that people are getting fired for saying mean shit.
But where is it?
It gets problematic when it's a difference of opinion and it's not necessarily a
mean insulting thing or a negative thing,
but it's a philosophical difference of opinion.
You know,
like sometimes people say things and although it's not smart,
what they said,
what they said probably shouldn't get them fired,
just is a gray area when it comes to some of these things.
Well,
if everyone was honest,
I would say yeah,
but they're not.
What happens,
the guy like Trevor Noah does is tweet a few years ago and then they go back and
they know they're jokes,
but they lie and they go look at this hateful thing about Jews.
He doesn't like,
he's antisemitic.
So they take things that they know are men for jokes and they spin them into
this was hate speech.
And it's almost like because there are such liars just to get a result that
that's where the confusing part comes in.
Because if,
if,
if it was just left alone yet,
it dilutes their opinion because then,
you know,
I'm not going to listen to anything you say.
If you say that is Joe,
like he had one joke,
she's 10 times the woman that she used to be.
So I guess she's fat now.
They're like,
oh,
she's,
he's fat shaming.
No,
he's making a joke.
Yes.
Yeah.
And what are you saying that someone has 10 times the size they used to be isn't
fat cause I'd say that's pretty fucking dishonest.
Sure.
Unless they weighed six pounds at one point.
This idea of fat shaming has been driving me fucking crazy.
Like it's not,
I like the fanny pack by the way.
Thank you very much.
Louis was really,
Louie wanted to spit in my face this morning when he saw it.
Dare he?
I know he's got a fanny pack.
I have one for you if you want one.
I think you get a new one.
I have one of yours too.
Yeah,
I like a good fanny pack so I do as well.
I forgot what I said.
I got all excited.
You're talking about fat shaming.
Yeah,
I mean look man,
it's not cool to be mean to people.
It's not cool to like point someone out and be mean to him,
but it's not smart to just let it go either.
It's not smart to just not ever talk about someone's weight like you.
If you care about someone,
you should probably bring up the fact that they're morbidly obese.
If you could bring it up and have them realize that there's other options out
there and they change their,
their habits,
that's not,
that's not necessarily fat shaming.
If we're all ignoring fat people or ignoring people that have eating problems,
we're going to ignore like a,
a serious health problem.
That's,
that's,
uh,
that's as much of an addiction as what you were talking about.
What about sex?
Sure.
It's the same sort of thing.
They get in their head,
they get sweaty thinking about ring dings and Ho hos and cakes and Burgers,
and it's just a fucking sheer joy of gluttony given into it.
Yeah.
Bring things are fucking awesome though.
I gotta be honest.
I have friends that have a food,
food addictions,
and I've been around them.
When they satisfy those addictions,
it's like you're watching the lions eat.
It's the hardest.
It's the hardest of all the food.
Fucking brutal,
man.
You gotta,
you gotta eat.
You have to eat right.
Exactly.
It,
you don't have to go to hookers.
Right.
Some of us do Joe,
but you know what I'm saying?
You don't like,
you'll live if you don't get a hooker,
you won't live if you don't eat right.
You have to eat.
So he like constantly dive the dancing in and out of this world that they're
addicted to very hard.
It's like you can't not do it.
Well I'm eating healthy.
Like I dated this Gal wants back in the day who had a bit of a weight problem
and she um,
she and I had a discussion about at once where I was like,
um,
I think that you,
you put so much emphasis on this issue and it was a very minor weight problem.
And what she wasn't morbidly obese by anyone's definition.
Um,
but she did like would gain like a little 10 pounds here,
a little 20 pounds there and it bothered her and what bothered her was that it
would obsess her all day and she would talk about what she ate.
I had a fat free muffin ahead of this and I had of that and it became like
almost this and like this,
this battle that she could never,
when she was as crazy Yoyo that who she just,
she knew that she wasn't supposed to have the ice cream,
so she had to eat the ice cream,
you know,
and then whoa.
The way she fixed it is yoga.
She started doing yoga and the yoga somehow or another balanced her brain out
and the effort of doing the yoga boosted her metabolism and she started eating
really healthy because she got more conscious of her body be instead of just
like she,
she had always exercise.
He was always like pretty fit,
but she just would do like running or lift a little ways or something like this.
But this got her into doing yoga and then she became like really obsessed with
eating healthy foods and taking care of her body and you know,
then she turned out great.
That's great.
Yeah,
she figured it out,
which is cool when someone figures it out.
But,
but it was,
it was bizarre being in,
I've been next to friends,
like guy friends that have it,
but they just go in Hog wild and gluttony.
Well girls don't do that.
They kind of dance around it.
So their food addictions even weirder because like my friends that have food
addictions,
they'll indulge right in front of me,
you know,
like let's go,
you guys want to go to,
you know,
fill in the blank.
Let's go get some spaghetti and meatballs.
Fuck yeah.
And they sit down and then you seem indulging like,
oh this is fucking tremendous.
And you know,
they know they shouldn't be eating this but they're eating in any way.
And it's hard to say something like,
you don't want to be the wet nurse.
But then it's like,
you know,
I'm 46 and my friends were in their forties it's like you can drop dead at this
point.
Oh yeah.
You certainly can.
And have,
you know like already what worried me when he was in here,
I was like Jesus Christ and I was telling them about healthy foods and you know,
just got the pill thing to the heroin thing too.
And it's like,
God damn dude,
you're putting a lot of pressure on your heart.
How long ago did you have him?
Not long ago.
Okay.
He's,
he looks like he's lost a few pounds.
Actually I saw him recently.
Yeah,
we get a Gig in Florida and as he looks a little thinner,
I'm like,
you make it an effort.
Funny.
Fuck.
Yeah,
he's really fucking funny.
He was so funny on the podcast talking about sports gambling,
which he's got a thing for just as bad as you ever think for said.
Oh really?
He fucking loves gambling and he loves gambling and it's that same thing.
It's that,
that impulsive shit that comics tend to get.
We get,
there's like a lot of us get like,
we have real addiction problems.
The really funny ones,
like for whatever reason,
like I know a lot of guys that have either a sexual addiction or some sort of
drug addiction or a gambling addiction or some sort of addiction,
like it's a real common,
I know guys that have relationship addictions where their addiction is to be
constantly in conflict and the relationships and they never straightened it out
and they're always scared to be alone and they'll like scared,
scared to lose a cow and then they fight like cats and dogs and they always,
I got to get away from her and then they never do and then there's aids.
But what you're,
what you're doing is the same sort of crazy thing that a food person does.
Well you just back and forth and back and forth in that conflict becomes like
what you were talking about with the sex where you never see yourself,
you never see life.
You're looking at,
like you said,
through a window,
you never right there,
you never totally present.
You're always involved in this inner battle.
And that inner battle could be gambling,
it could be beaten off,
it could be going to hookers,
there could be doing drugs,
it could be drinking.
Whatever you're trying to not do becomes your thing.
It could be food,
whatever you're trying to not do becomes this wrestling match that you're
constantly engaged in all day.
And for me,
I had a,
I've had a bunch of them,
I've got a bunch of 'em um,
various games.
I've had a bunch of,
with video games,
with playing pool,
like real bad man where I,
you know,
with video games it was real bad.
Like I would be sitting there talking to somebody and I'd be like,
this is so much more boring than playing a video game.
I want to go play a video of them right now.
And I just wanted to get away and go play a video game.
And I would just go into my office and shut the door and just like finally put
the headphones on and then I would play.
And then I realized like,
wow,
this is like I'm in,
I'm doing,
I'm an addict here.
Adequate.
Like what's the long period of time?
Eight,
10 hours.
Wow.
Really?
Yeah.
12 sometimes I would do 12 I would do like six at night to six in the morning.
Easy.
Oh,
like fueled with a caffeine.
Australian girl had a heart attack.
I used to buy these sodas.
I forget the company that made them,
they were really cool and some of them were blue,
some of them had Jalapeno in them.
Some of them had like extreme amounts of caffeine and them and Guarana and all
these and they had like skulls and all these different weird artsy labels.
And there was this supermarket in north Hollywood that used to sell them down
the street from my apartment and I would go and I would buy them by the fucking
crate.
I would buy like everything they had when they would get new shipments in.
I even contacted the people that made the soft drink.
They had a warehouse in the factory and I said,
can I come to your warehouse and just buy some cases of your shit?
And it had like all sorts of different hot peppers in it and crazy,
but it was super caffeinated and I would drink this stuff and just play video
games just all night long.
Did you do it for,
that's the shit.
No,
that's not it.
Actually.
Green Apple,
Jalapenos,
soda.
Um,
it looked a little bit like the stuff in the upper left hand.
There's a bunch of different ones,
but they had like skulls and all kinds of weird shit all over the um,
the uh,
the labels.
How many years ago is,
this isn't the nineties.
And how many,
how long did you do for a,
I think I quit video games altogether around 2000.
I think I realized I started playing like every now and again.
And like the early two thousands,
I would play like a little lever here and then,
but I didn't take,
I never,
I never got into it seriously again.
And then I completely stopped playing,
um,
around 2002 the graphics now.
And go like,
yeah,
I get scared.
Yeah,
it's still there.
It's,
here's the thing about it.
If you're a Gamer and you're like,
boom,
folks room with you,
you know you do do a lot.
You're right.
There's nothing wrong with playing video games.
They're fun as hell.
The problem is if you have some other stuff that you want to do in your life,
you got to know like what?
Like if I get addicted to Jujitsu,
here's a,
here's a perfect example.
I can't do Jujitsu,
but an hour and a half a day you get exhausted.
Like you keep your body just can't keep up.
You can't keep doing it like you,
there's only a certain amount of hours in a day that you could roll because
you're straining your fucking cardio and you're,
you're trying to survive and you're trying to kill and you're fucking constantly
moving and you're constantly trying to,
you know,
a better your position and defend and after a you're done,
you're done.
You can.
It's not like that with video games,
with video games,
if you're addicted to it,
you fucking can play eight,
10 hours a day.
It's not a problem if you get the right caffeine in you and you've got to write
the right kind of addictive game,
especially if you have friends and you're playing to get,
Luis said,
playboy land parties.
We used to get there and link all of our computers together.
Oh my God.
We'd be up for days.
People would just,
well we,
I would go to Houston and have gigs in Houston.
A lot of the guys would be from Houston.
We'd meet in Houston and we link up our computers together and we would play
four fucking hours and hours and hours and we'd come day after day.
Like we'd have like a two or three day thing where we'd all get together.
It's just burnout,
junk food,
chips,
mountain,
do whatever the fuck kind of caffeine you can get into your system.
It's just too,
it's too fun.
It's a really fun thing to do.
Yeah.
But I,
I play asteroids.
When I was a kid,
I was very addicted.
Like I played every I,
but I'm that,
I'm that of that ilk,
so I never got into them as an adult.
Yeah.
Well,
I think they can get there but as a form of entertainment they're fucking
awesome and even better today than ever before.
You know it's funny cause I was in one of the grand theft auto and I had like a
little line or whatever and I tried playing it.
Laszlo,
this Guy Laszlo came into opie and Anthony and I kept,
I played that whole month.
I backed into the fence six times and said fuck this,
I am such an uncoordinated twat that I just couldn't make it work.
Thank I.
I literally look back on that and I go thank God you backed into the fence
because I live.
I know that it would have been fun but once you figured out how to use the
controllers and a video game and you really do become like a part of the way you
move.
Like with quake,
every guy had like a script that he would run that he would load up like a
profile script for the speed of your mouse for the shape of your character for
your name and you can upload it.
Like you could have it as a text file on your computer and you upload it into
the game and then like that would be like your speed of your mouse.
Like some people like the mouse to move really fast.
Some people like the mouse to move really slow.
Some people like an extended view,
like your Pov could change,
like your Pov could be they're 90 or one 27 guys are spread it out and they give
you like a fish eye lens and allow you to see more shit on your screen.
And some guys like that and some guys didn't,
but it was this thing that it became like really specific so that you got super
used to the amount of movement that you would do with your fingers and how that
would calculate into moving on screen and your brain's sinked up to it.
So then you didn't even think about moving your fingers.
It just automatically happen.
And when you're playing eight,
10 hours a day,
day after day after day,
it becomes like really become second nature.
Yeah.
Anthony's a big Gamer and he would always play on the computer.
He preferred that to Joyce and I never could understand playing on the computer
left right kit,
this key,
this guy,
I couldn't get it.
Well the reason is when you use a mouse,
a mouse and a keyboard is the most accurate form of controller for video games.
So far like you can get a lot done with one of those x-box controllers but
you're never going to get the type of pinpoint accuracy in like a first person
shooter especially.
Oh you can with a mouse with a mouse.
You could turn around and like look at a guy like there's certain guys that
would play like there's this kid is to calm fatality.
He's calm himself.
Fatality and the uh,
the,
the I and fatality was like a number one and he is like a world champion quake
player.
And when you would watch him play,
he would make these split second turns and shoot guys in the face that were
falling off of buildings.
Like guys would like we jumping off of buildings and he would spin and in midair
they would explode.
And he just had this,
this super tight tuned in sense of what the cursor was doing on a screen as he
was moving.
And if you watch some of the really high level quick guys,
when they would play in what these things are called,
they're called demos and they
can make a demo and then they could upload the demo and you could watch a match
take place from their point of view and you could see how,
how well they move in the game and it was just like my God.
Like when you get to the really high levels of the game,
it's insanely adrenaline filled because you're going down dark corridors,
people are shooting at you,
you're shooting at them,
your health is deteriorating before your eyes.
You're running to try to get more health.
You're running to try to get armor and new weapons and you're trying to control
the map and waiting for the new weapon to respond.
You've got to get to this area within five seconds.
He'd have to time it all out in your head.
You have to know the map inside and out.
It becomes insanely addictive.
And the,
the,
the rush,
the actual rush that you would get from these games is incredible.
I mean,
it's just adrenaline pumping,
heart beating,
three dimensional graphics sound you have headphones on.
So you,
you're here three dimensional sound.
Like if you hear something to the right,
that means someone is to your right.
Like they are actually two,
you're right in the game and you run towards them and is these corridors and it
was amazing.
It's an amazing game because then it's just one of them backing into the fence
and saying,
fuck it.
I can't do it.
What's probably good for you?
Sorry,
I lost years of my life playing those games did and I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed it.
But I guarantee I lost years of my life.
Uh,
it could also coincided with a time where I wasn't white writing many jokes.
Coincidental.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Sometimes if something becomes obsessive,
I wanted,
there's a balance.
I want to have more fun stuff in my life that I do that's healthy and normal,
but you know,
I don't want to get addicted to anything else.
I don't want to put down one addiction and I hope I can just stay away from this
one for awhile.
I've,
I've been keeping a running tally is the first time I ever did that.
A running tally financially.
Oh really?
Yes.
Of how much you spending on that stuff?
It's quite a bit.
It's not,
I mean it's not,
you know,
I've put his way in a year of,
I spent more than Charlie Sheen.
Sure.
I mean that,
I mean that one year that he talked to $50,000 in a year.
I was like,
I mean often I would say it's nothing but I've done more and I'll make Charlie
sheen money.
Wow.
Not every year and not up to this point this year.
Well,
if you can replace it with something,
isn't that what your mom wants to tell you?
That mom message to Phil said you can go to the gym and that was in 2003 I put
that on my second CD.
A mother made a very good point.
She said,
just go to the gym.
You can meet nice girls to the senior ladies of the evening getting shape.
And she was right.
I did do that.
But I mean she called it ladies of the evening too,
right?
I don't know.
I forget what it was called.
The time it's,
yeah,
I don't remember what she called it.
I might even have it on my foot.
If you,
if you picked up a game,
like,
I hate to say it,
but even golf,
like golf becomes very addiction.
It takes a lot of time and guys do it for like long hours in the day,
but it's also fun.
You go with your buddies,
you'd go and fos,
he could've no you all day and he'd go and knock.
We ain't Voss plays basically every fucking day.
Right.
But I don't sleep well enough to pull it off either.
My sleep's a big issue like I,
and I feel like this is why I get so frustrated and angry and just self hating
because
I tried to do the right thing.
Like I'll put the mask on big boy when God is Tessa,
went to three apnea test,
still can't do it.
Claustrophobic.
I fucking finally fall asleep and then I hear
and I realize that the air is blowing out the side of the mask.
It's like everything.
Nothing syncs up,
right.
Despite my best efforts.
And it's almost like you're always taught if you do the right thing,
the right thing.
I've done all the legwork and I'm still getting fucking dog shit results and it
makes me nuts.
It makes me so I want to smash my face to a fucking window because I've done the
right stuff and I still can't fall asleep.
And you're asleep at Mo.
Maybe someone listening to this can shed some light or help you out in some sort
of war.
Probably not though because I bet you've talked about this on the radio enough
times where someone has explored all the options with you.
I have something called a complex apnea.
It's central apnea and it's obstructive.
Like I was falling asleep on the plane.
I flew out here today and I just kept,
it felt like someone was just fucking put a sock in my mouth.
It was a,
it was like my fucking dub tongue lolled back over my throat.
And then if it,
but if it's not that I have a mouth guard,
I use not the one you use,
but I have one that does hold my jaw forward,
then it's a central apnea.
When my tongue's not blocking things,
my brain just goes,
don't breathe.
You don't breathe.
So the ASV machine I have,
which I've tried c pap and APAP and bypass and all that shit ASV is the
combination that they supposed to work with.
Complex apnea is very,
very intuitive machine.
Like it really picks up your breathing and it works with you.
Even though they can't sleep with John Dam,
it stinks.
So when you put that thing on that you just can't get a good night's sleep.
No,
no,
because I get claustrophobic,
claustrophobic,
mass cause on your face and tries to be nuts from stuffy.
My douchey nose is stuffy.
Fucking Jimmy Norton's cunt nose is stuffy.
It makes me so frustrated.
And you think that the nose thing has something to do with allergies?
So yeah,
big thing.
Big thing.
I mean,
you know,
I think so.
Are we all crazy?
Are All comics crazy?
Yeah.
But I mean like literally.
I'm not getting the air and they had physically it's the truth.
You know we yet,
yes.
I think those things are both true.
I think we are all nuts and I do think that I just can't breathe.
Well.
Do you monitor your diet to keep your diet free of things that cause
inflammation or anything?
Probably.
You know what's funny?
I have a feeling that certain things do it.
Like we'd probably does it to me.
I know when I eat Sushi I'm a throat clearing jerk off by things like uh,
you know,
even the fat,
anything milk oriented bothers me.
So certain foods I can avoid and that and that makes it easier.
I use a breathe right strip.
Does that help?
Yeah,
a little bit.
I mean that and plus the mouth,
the mouth guard,
the one you got.
I want to try to get up because I have central apnea too.
It won't fix it at the mouth guard has changed my life a little bit because it
does keep my throat open.
So like a lot of times I am probably choking far less often like that I did.
I,
you know what I mean?
That I would be normally,
so it's helped me a lot.
But um,
you know,
I just talked about this on the radio the other day with it be like,
one of the reasons that when opie
and Anthony had their fight recently and they,
they're actually cool.
It was,
I missed that fight.
I our heard ob talking about it.
No,
you know what I heard you talking about opie crying on the radio talking about
it,
but I missed the whole thing.
Yeah,
it was,
Anthony had had said some shit about open,
then open responded.
Um,
but you know what,
what did they say?
Um,
what the hell did answer,
he was just talking about how it was difficult to work with him all these years
and the stuff with his girlfriend,
he went through a history of why there's bad blood.
It's just got to the point where I could tell on Twitter that those guys were,
we're going to go,
I could sent it.
Um,
and I never said to Andrew,
you're going to bad mouth open.
I never said dopey.
What are you feeling?
Like it's see through their tweets that some things that either one of them were
saying we're being misinterpreted.
It was just going to happen.
So aunt,
you know,
opens it a few things on Twitter or on the show that I think misinterpreted or
even interpreted.
Right?
And got Mad,
but combination of both.
So whatever that fucking snipping at each other.
And then when it went,
oop,
went back at him the next day,
like you have to aunt really set some stuff on the compound show old.
He came back and he was pissed off.
And uh,
I was in a weird position only cause I'm like,
I'm not going to sit here and just play devil's advocate for Anthony because
aunt needs to do that.
Like they need to do that together.
And it almost seemed unfair for me to just sit there and argue with opie.
Like,
I'm Anthony's mouthpiece,
but you know what I mean.
And so I even said I didn't want to do that.
There's a couple of points.
I clarified things and I thought Ann had made a valid point about,
but I wasn't gonna just sit there and argue with opie over it like that,
that's let him,
and he had fucking do that shit.
Like I'm not,
I'm not that codependent.
It's like,
let them fuck it.
But,
um,
but I've got like,
it was legit.
Two people thought it might have been like manipulate,
but I watched it happen and you know,
nobody wants to do that shit.
Like that's embarrassing shit when you're,
you know,
especially a fucking audience like that.
Nobody wants to solve.
I on the fucking awful did he saw it wasn't,
it wasn't like a little,
it was a little,
it
wasn't that bad,
but he kind of caught himself and he didn't want,
it was like,
you know,
it was like a little bit the I,
but he just,
you know,
he was over in remembering nice stuff.
It was remembering Nice Shit.
And,
uh,
I forget what I was to,
what was I saying?
I was just talking about something.
Why don't they go down this road?
Um,
I don't remember either.
I was talking about breathing and about my fucking why did I go down this road?
You talking about Oop,
bad mouthing,
um,
that they,
they fought back and forth.
No,
but there was a reason I went down that road then maybe think of those guys and
I don't remember what it was or that people listening online.
Does anybody know?
I legitimately just lost my place.
I would say little,
someone will say it right now on Twitter.
Yeah.
Like what was I saying?
That made me,
cause it was the reason I went down the road about them fighting about something
that got talked about.
It was something I said after or something I thought of that one of them said,
I don't know.
God dammit.
I don't know what it was.
I had no one that me going down that row was spawned by thinking of something
else.
Motherfucker.
God Damn it.
I'm not saying waiting for someone to,
maybe there's a woman I'm looking at with chips,
tweets.
The wonder,
I'm not getting any fucking real information.
Ships that mansion you have Twitter.
Chip is a separate character that you a tweet through him and Ed,
you're both have their own Twitter.
Of course.
I'm sure the chip has 44,000 followers.
Chip has a,
you know,
yeah,
he's a fucking,
he's a force.
Let me see here now on Jim Norton's.
Let's see how many,
I'm trying to see anybody's mad.
Apologize for stolen like this.
And that's hilarious.
I didn't mean to go down that road.
Someone will find it.
We're going to get corrected on line,
but I want to know because there was a point I was making the mask
on the show.
No,
but I don't know.
Window went down the opie and Anthony thing.
There was something,
I was thinking of it.
I literally just lost my place.
That's how tired I am.
I don't know.
You know,
let me tell you something.
Maybe it will help you.
Um,
you know what I really liked is that fucking thing that you wrote about Trevor
Noah.
Oh,
thank you.
That thing you wrote for Time magazine.
Thank you.
That was really smart.
That's really appropriate and exactly.
You are exactly right.
The outrage was manufactured.
It was its recreational outrage there.
They found something,
a green light to be a dick about and they decided to be a dick about it.
And you wrote a really well thought out piece about that.
Thank you.
Yeah,
it was just,
it was just the uh,
Trevor Noah is,
and the problem you are,
it's kind of hard sometimes.
Like the good thing about writing is you have a time to edit and you can get
your thoughts in a row instead of just reacting angrily.
He don't even have a,
like a flood of thoughts come normally or explain this best.
Like he,
when you have a bunch of thoughts and you just want to get them all out,
there's been certain things I wanted to write about but I couldn't cause you get
blocked by the frustration.
What do I want to say?
And Norman.
Leah said,
his therapist said,
damn,
years ago,
picture it like a room that's on fire.
Do we talk about this?
He said,
when you win,
everybody rushes to the door,
they get stuck.
But if everybody walks out of the room one at a time,
everyone gets out and then you can section them off into people by height and
people by color and couple of them.
That's the way it is with thoughts.
So it's almost like all this frustration,
I'll just talk it into this thing,
but I did.
I just get the fuck out one at a time,
one at a time and then formulate it.
Cause something like that where there's so many,
you have so many feelings about it.
It's hard not to try it.
We try hard not to be self righteous as comedians.
You really tried to,
just to make your thoughts known.
We all fall into it once in a while.
Every person does it,
but it's,
it's,
it's hard.
You don't want to cause that's a Dick Quality.
Yeah,
it's,
well it's,
there's a balancing act where you're creating something.
It's like,
what tone am I trying to set here?
What's the best way to get this thought out where it's got the most impact?
How do I really feel about it versus what's the most entertaining version of it
that I could say,
you know,
how much do I twist it for just for humor?
How much did I fuck around with it?
You know,
and it's,
that's the beautiful thing about standup is that it's all coming from your
direction.
You can decide where to it and tweak it.
And so you're going to have those little battles in your head about where to
take things.
Yeah.
I mean,
um,
but it's like when they,
I always write,
it's funny,
this is why fans are great,
cause I wrote that piece and then I get people get mad at me.
Why didn't you write one about aunt say,
first of all,
I have to talk about him on stage and he's my special.
Second of all,
they didn't ask me to,
I don't,
I don't call them and ask.
They just asked me.
Um,
you know,
they've,
I've turned them down for things.
I didn't think I was qualified to write about it.
I'm like,
no,
I'm not going to address that.
So how does that go?
Like wait,
they say,
would you like to write something about Trevor Noah?
Look,
you have a relationship with them.
When they do that,
they'll write to me and say,
would you write something about Trevor?
Or they've written me when Robyn died.
They're like,
would you like to write something?
I'm like,
yeah,
but they asked him that Joan Rivers.
I said no,
only because I loved her,
but I wasn't,
I just felt like so many people are gonna be eulogizing let people who are
better qualified to do it.
Cause I really didn't know her.
So of Joan Rivers was Patrice,
you would've written something.
Oh,
of course.
If they asked me to.
Um,
but again,
you have to get away.
I just,
it was only like,
I didn't know her well enough and I would have been talking about her,
but not from a knowledgeable point of view.
As someone who interacted with Joan a lot,
I was a huge fan.
I was bummed out that I never got to meet her.
I really wish I got to meet her.
There was,
I was supposed to do,
uh,
in bed with Joan.
Oh yeah.
It was a podcast that you climb in bed with her and she would interview you from
bed and you know,
he'd just laugh around,
joke around with her.
I would have loved to have done it,
but for whatever reason,
scheduling wise,
it had to be moved around or,
and then obviously she died quite a while after that first time I met Joan
Rivers.
I was on a flight coming from,
I mean,
I loved her.
So I was on a flight coming from
West Palm Beach and I see Joan get on the plane and she's two seats in front of
me and to her assistant recognize me.
So as we're getting on the plane,
she's sitting there and she has a look up and I just said like,
get a hi,
I'm a comedian.
That's just,
you're just,
you're awesome.
I just think you're great.
She said,
thank you.
And then she's just,
you know,
she's like,
you don't look funny.
I'm like,
well not,
you know,
she was just like,
well,
so I sat down in moments like that.
I'm terrible by the way,
I'm the worst fun banter guy ever.
I stink at fun banter with anyone on elevators.
My ex would laugh at me cause somebody would walk on and go like,
oh boy,
this elevator slow and I'll just go,
yes it is like I'm a humorless content but it's not.
I just panicked.
So I sat down and then her assistant came over with a piece of the New York
Times and he handed it to me.
He's like,
Joan said you looked like he needed something to read.
So she gave me a piece of red paper and I want to take a photo with it.
I'm like,
can we take a photo after the plane landed?
And she goes,
yeah,
but not here.
So she walked me up to the top and she goes,
hop on.
And she had one of those lug does those things that they zip through the airport
with and she gave me a ride on her fucking thing.
We speed through the airport and then we took a photo,
a not a good photo of either one of us,
but I eventually got her to sign it from someone else.
And I had met her a couple of times after that and said,
brief hello is,
I don't think she remembered me.
And the last time I spoke to her,
I went to Louis C K had on Thanksgiving two years ago.
He had Joan Rivers at his house.
He had Philip Seymour Hoffman at his house and he invited me and a,
I said
hi to her.
Um,
wow.
You went to a dinner party with Phillip Seymour Hoffman and Joan Rivers at Louis
C K s house.
And that's amazing story.
Well,
this is why Louis is so Louis would tell a great story.
This is what Louis sell.
Incredible because he's unafraid.
Like someone told me,
I think Nick Depaulo was there.
Bobby Bobby Kelly was so funny that day.
I panic.
I'm just looking at Phillip Seymour Hoffman.
You know,
I sent a lighter,
just myself.
Um,
you know,
but I'm,
I'm not good in those moments.
Bob Kelly's just be a fucking Dag.
He's breaking balls.
He a big funny ox,
you know,
shit talker,
bully guy.
Just moments like that.
It really loved Bobby because he's just,
he's so good at being funny in those moments.
You don't like the ball breaker from Boston that he is.
And Bobby's a guy who like in those moments like metal,
who the guy is who tries to Alpha Bob.
Bob Is,
Bob is a,
is a,
a Yorkshire terrier who would be slaughtered by a pit bull because Bob's the guy
who really doesn't back off it from anybody.
Like that's why he's funny cause like someone tries to Alpha him and be funny
and by ain't not dead,
he just,
and he's just,
you know,
but,
but that works for him,
you know what I mean?
So I really admired Bobby that day cause he was so funny in front of Phillip's
from a hop and all these other people and Ellen Burstyn was there.
Um,
you know,
and I'm just staring at her like she's doing the extra system.
Yeah,
it was that she was in the [inaudible].
She played the mother in the exorcist.
Really?
Yeah.
So what a bizarre partner.
He knows the fucking weirdest people.
Um,
and he's awesome.
And he was making Thanksgiving and Joan was helping him.
And I think Nick Depalo told me that Louie had never done this.
That's why he's got such courage because he'll do something like that.
That's why he's show works.
Cause he takes risks.
You know,
I'm fucking,
I'm Samuel to shy sea lion.
I just want to sit back until it's all in a row and everything's fucking so this
is a Thanksgiving dinner parties.
It was Thanksgiving two years ago.
Oh.
And Phillips showed up with his kids and it sounds amazing.
Parker Posey was there.
Um,
and,
and fucking,
by the way,
I met the Cappuccino machine.
Bobby and I are trying to make Cappuccino and Philip Seymour Hoffman comes over
and I'm just like,
look for making kappa cheat all.
Yeah.
I'm so star struck like a cunt and Bob's just being funny.
Bob's just being him in that moment,
you know,
he's able to be him and be funny.
And I was like fucking so jealous of Bob that he could be so funny there.
But Anyway,
Joan was there and uh,
when she,
I was just it all over.
I couldn't even speak to her.
She was there with Melissa and switched.
You walked out.
I'm like pre or post meeting or on the point.
Oh,
so all of those posts.
So she left and I said goodbye Ms. Right.
It was nice seeing you Joan,
which was like,
oh,
okay.
Like literally she had no recognition of me and I saw Louis after that and I was
like,
God,
it really hurts my feelings that she doesn't know who I am.
And I'm not like that or any comedian.
I'm not uncomfortable around comedians.
I'm not nervous around comedians.
Uh,
cause I figure we all know each other in some way,
but around her I was always like fucking head down here.
It gets bad and all that.
I was like John Candy and stripes and Larry Cat's yelling at him,
shut up.
Okay,
sure.
I always had like that thing with Joan Rivers because she was just,
I didn't want her to not like me because she was just such a fucking icon.
It would have Louis say when you told him that he was nice though.
He was smart.
He goes,
you gotta remember she's healed with this.
We Louie so logical Louise like you know,
Geez fucking an 80 year old woman.
You know she's put,
but that's how he is.
You know,
you forget cause she's had work done.
She's fucking 80 she doesn't know anybody and I'm like,
he's right.
Even though she was still fucking totally sharp.
But she was an 80 year old woman at that time.
So of course,
you know,
maybe like the face,
it didn't ring as much of a bell as they should have,
which is also insanely famous for so many fucking years where she's probably all
day talking to people that want a piece of her all day.
They want to talk,
don't want pictures.
They wanted this,
they wanted that.
They should probably just can't remember it all.
It's 50 fucking years of that and show business everybody.
And that's how it was for me.
That Ozzy Osborne,
like I've met Ozzy so many times and when he finally knew me,
like I knew he knew him.
Hey Man,
anybody I knew it was really,
it's like,
you know,
hey man,
you look right,
how are you?
And he was like,
it was like really the way I would greet Joe Rogan.
Like it was just a buddy.
And like when that happened,
I was like,
my fucking life is good.
But Joe and I never had that with,
and I wish I had because she's one of them.
But she was one of my longest running aisles.
Like I really loved her.
She was not,
and not just cause she don't eat if someone dies,
how many waxes poetic about them.
But I thought she was fucking great.
She's a ballsy lady.
She was a very ballsy lady.
Very brave.
She was braver than any of us,
cause she never said she was sorry.
And she had so much to lose as far as the,
you know,
I mean I interviewed one time,
what was his name?
Henry Bush going to,
he was Johnny's hold lawyer,
Carson's old lawyer and he wrote a book recently.
I wonder how Carson would have felt about him.
The old lawyer write a book,
but he told all the old stories and I asked him about Joan Rivers and he had a
very interesting perspective on how Carson never would have,
he said he wouldn't have cared.
He said Carson didn't think she would last and late night cause she was a little
too abrasive to be watched.
I mean like,
you know,
Johnny was a smart fucking guy,
but Henry Bush kitten was a really,
well,
it didn't need to Carson go bad on her.
Didn't they have some sort of a falling out with Johnny was apparently a cold
mother.
Her mother was really cold and boy did it not the apple didn't fall far from the
tree.
He would do Joan,
this is what I,
and Joan got the show and her,
uh,
husband Edgar said she should do her own talk show.
I believe it started at 11 or 1130.
It was up against Johnny.
She did it because she was never considered for the permanent guest host job.
And she was hurt by that and she had had a career.
But apparently they had hung out with Johnny and not told him that she,
and I think if she had walked up to Carson and said,
Johnny,
look,
I have this opportunity according to Henry Bush get and Johnny's lawyer,
Johnny would have wished your well because he didn't think,
he didn't think she had the,
the longevity and late night just because of how she was.
And he might've been right because you look at,
Carson was so easy breezy and he had that fucking way and he lasted and John's
show lasted a little bit,
but it didn't last.
So I don't know.
But,
uh,
I guess he felt that she had betrayed him and he never spoke to her again.
And I think she tried to call him once and he hung up on her and never,
she said she sent him a note when his son died.
His son drove off a cliff and died.
No response.
He was a cold motherfucker.
Johnny man,
when he was done
with you,
he was done fucking finished.
And so when she drove off a cliff,
well by mistake,
I think it was an accident,
I don't think it was a suicide.
His son Chris and I also heard the fucking one Jane,
when Johnny was eulogizing his son on the tonight show,
fucking Fred de Cordova who was his exact producer.
Give him like the wrap sign,
like to move it like because of commercial was coming.
And I heard the Carson never forgave him either and he was never allowed on the
floor of the tonight show again.
Johnny banished him to upstairs,
which again,
these are just,
you know,
third and fourth hand shit stories say I'm anyway,
absolutely repeat them as Gospel.
But you Snopes this.
But the fact that you fucking not those are true,
but the fact that you like almost like with TV people,
what are you thinking when this guy who is such a god on television is fucking
eulogizing his son and you're wrapping them up,
what are you thinking?
That fucking pampers can't wait five minutes.
Like what's going to happen to the show?
If you let them go.
Speaking of what's going to happen to show this one has to end.
Yes it does.
We've been talking for awhile.
This is good though.
Yeah.
We got to do this more often.
I love it too.
When I'm out here.
This is,
I love doing you and uh,
it's my favorite one to do.
I mean,
I love Adam and I love,
but you know,
you,
I know for so many years,
so this is the most fun I had.
If we've known each other a long fucking time.
Dude.
Like I said,
we met in like what,
90,
91.
Uh,
yeah,
doing the the quarter deck and I still am I talking,
I remember your Mike Tyson joke about how scary it must have been when fucking
Mike showed up and Brad Pitt was worth and you're like,
you're checking a check you off you for a second.
And you did the Mike Tyson impression and you,
you were,
uh,
you were very funny and you're very animated and a very powerful comic to it.
I know you use that word a lot,
but that was,
that was how you struck me early on.
You had a tremendous amount of fucking force on stage and um,
you know,
and I was up there just meek doing high energy.
Fucking faggoty Jimmy,
how are you doing?
Like me,
I went though and I always liked you.
I think you start,
you are funny.
You're very nice.
No,
but it's interesting when you've gone through a journey like that with someone
when you've been friends since you were both starting out.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's weird.
It's weird when you go back and you look at all the time that's passed and how
much each one of us has evolved and grown,
you know,
it's cool to see someone that you started out with being really successful too.
I'm really psyched for you.
Thank you man.
Yeah,
I hope people like the new special economic love it.
They'll love you.
So one of the best comics working today,
I really believe that.
Thank you very much.
And the best comics in the world.
You got good morning gentleman,
Jim Norton,
one of the best comics in the world,
and you get get them on Twitter.
Jim Norton on Twitter.
You could fucking email him.
He'll email you back if you're not a douche bag.
[inaudible] it's the Real Jim Norton at g mail.
Um,
you could see the special April 24th,
Friday night,
April 24th on Epix,
epix h t.com.
I think if you don't get epic's luxurious.
Thank you,
my brother.
Thanks for hanging with Ya.
Yes,
I can't believe it.
Okay.